la séance est reprise bonjour monsieur
le ministre l'ordre du jour jour pardon
appelle une déclaration du gouvernement
suivie d'un débat en application de
l'article 50 1 de la constitution sur le
projet de programme de stabilité pour
2027 la parole est à monsieur gabriel
attal ministre délégué chargé des
comptes publics monsieur le ministre
c'est à vous
madame la présidente monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général
de 50-1 de la constitution j'ai
l'honneur de vous présenter le programme
de stabilité pour la période 2000 22
2027 qui sera prochainement transmis à
la commission européenne
comme chaque année ce programme détaille
les prévisions de croissance et la
trajectoire de finances publiques que le
gouvernement à déterminer mais je veux
le dire d'emblée ce programme de
stabilité est aussi l'occasion de
réaffirmer ce qui est le coeur de notre
stratégie en matière économique et en
matière de finances publiques ce
programme de stabilité et donc avant
tout un programme dédié à la croissance
et au plein emploi en 2010 est le
président de la république s'était
engagé à sortir le pays du chômage de
masse d'un taux de chômage proche de 10
% de la population active nous sommes
revenus début 2022 et malgré la crise au
taux de 7 3% soit le plus bas niveau
depuis 15 ans nous l'avons fait grâce à
nos réformes la réforme du marché du
travail engagées dès l'été 2010 est pour
redonner aux employeurs des capacités à
embaucher et à créer des emplois dans
notre pays
de fait nous avons créé près de 1
million 300 mille emplois en cinq ans ce
sont un million trois cent mille
français qui ont retrouvé un travail un
espoir une dignité parce que notre
majorité a su mener ses réformes en 2018
nous avons fait voter la loi avenir
professionnel qui a révolutionné l'accès
à l'apprentissage et à la formation
notre pays comptait moins de 300 milles
apprentis chaque année il en compte
aujourd'hui plus de 700 milles c'est une
formidable réussite pour l'insertion de
nos jeunes dans la vie active une
formidable victoire contre le chômage
aujourd'hui ce qui paraissait impossible
est à portée de main oui le plein emploi
est possible dans notre pays il le sera
parce que nous allons poursuivre les
réformes et lever tous les freins à
l'accès à l'emploi les chiffres le
démontrent encore ce matin hier matin
pour être plus précis j'ai reçu les
dernières données de l'urssaf caisse
nationale qui montrent que le nombre de
déclarations d'embauché continue de
progresser de 2 9 % sur le deuxième
trimestre 2000 22 dans l'industrie les
déclarations d'embauché progresse de 9
6% sur un an c'est une victoire pour
l'emploi c'est aussi une victoire pour
le financement de notre protection
sociale
puisque la masse salariale soumises à
cotisations progresse de 11% en un an et
dépasse désormais de 7 7% son niveau
d'avant crise alors nous allons
poursuivre et accentuer nos efforts pour
atteindre le plein emploi d'ici 2027
autour de trois grandes réformes d'abord
la réforme de france travaille pour
mettre davantage en réseau les services
de pôle emploi et ceux des collectivités
locales dédiées à l'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'emploi et notamment des
allocataires du rsa depuis un an le
nombre de soyez au rsa recommencent à
baisser parce que nous créons des
emplois mais il faut aller plus loin
comme le président de la république s'y
est engagé nous renforcerons leur
accompagnement et l'effort de la
collectivité pour permettre leur
véritable insertion dans l'emploi
deuxième réforme la poursuite de
l'apprentissage qui devra atteindre un
million de contrats d'ici la fin du
quinquennat et permettra de continuer à
réduire le chômage des jeunes parce que
nous préférons encourager l'accès à
l'apprentissage plutôt que d'ouvrir le
rsa aux jeunes comme certains le
proposent dans cet hémicycle la réforme
de l'assurance chômage enfin pour
assurer que chaque français trouvent
toujours un gain au travail et faire en
sorte que celui-ci soit mieux rémunéré
je veux rappeler qu'avec ces hausses
successives y compris celle intervenue
il ya quelques jours à hauteur de 2 0 1%
le smic a augmenté de 8 % en un an
aujourd'hui un salarié au smic touchent
1329 euros nets et touchera avec la
revalorisation de 4% prévu un projet de
loi pouvoir d'achat
239 euros de primes d'activité soit un
total de 1500 68 euros nets mais nous
devons continuer à assurer ce gain au
travail et mon collègue olivier dussopt
pts mènera dès la rentrée une
concertation en ce sens avec les
partenaires sociaux pour modifier à
nouveau les règles de l'assurance
chômage voilà l'objectif numéro un de ce
programme de stabilité favoriser la
croissance pour atteindre le plein
emploi je viens de vous exposer les
réformes que nous engageons pour y
parvenir ce programme de stabilité
traduit un autre engagement fondamental
pris par le président de la république
durant la campagne présidentielle celui
de tenir nos comptes avant de présenter
le cadre général permettez-moi de
revenir très brièvement sur le contexte
économique dans lequel nous sommes vous
le savez la très forte reprise
économique en 1021 après la levée des
restrictions qui ont été imposées par
l'épidémie de covin 19 puis l'invasion
de l'ukraine depuis février dernier nous
ont fait entrer dans une période de
forte hausse des prix cette dynamique
nous l'avions anticipé c'est d'ailleurs
la raison pour laquelle nous avons pris
des mesures dès l'automne 2021 et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
présenté les deux textes à l'ordre du
jour de cette session extraordinaire
contenant plus de 20 milliards d'euros
de mesures supplémentaires pour protéger
nos compatriotes
les choix que nous faisons les mesures
que vous portez que vous adoptez dans
cet hémicycle ont un impact direct sur
l'évolution de l'inflation je rappelle
d'ailleurs que l'insee a estimé que les
mesures du bouclier paris fer sur le gaz
et l'électricité prises dès l'automne
2000 21 ont permis d'éviter deux points
d'inflation à nos compatriotes
cette dynamique de stabilisation de
l'inflation nous l'espérons est
enclenché je rappelle les prévisions qui
ont été relayés par bruno le maire une
inflation qui atteindrait son pic dans
les prochaines semaines ou les prochains
mois commenceraient à décroître pour
atteindre une décrue réel dans le
courant ou la fin de l'année 2023 nous
restons évidemment tributaire de
l'évolution des marchés mondiaux et du
contexte géopolitique mais cette
possible stabilisation nous permet dans
le cadre de ce programme de stabilité de
tabler sur un atterrissage à 5% en
moyenne cette année suivi d'une hausse
de 3 2% en 2023 avant de redescendre
sous la barre des 2% cours en 2024 en
cohérence avec les objectifs de la
banque centrale européenne
autre bonne nouvelle que je veux
partager avec vous le chiffre de la
croissance de +0 5% pour le deuxième
trimestre ce signal positif atteste du
dynamisme et de la robustesse de notre
économie malgré le climat d'incertitude
qui pèse notamment sur la consommation
des ménages
concrètement cela veut dire que nous
avons d'ores et déjà acquis 2 5% de
croissance cette année c'est l'objectif
révisé que nous avions pour la fin de
l'année elle c'est à dire que nous avons
conjurer toutes les menaces ou relever
tous les défis évidemment non mais dans
cette période où l'inquiétude gagne les
ménages comme les entreprises il me
semble essentiel de rappeler qu'il
existe un scénario favorable celui de la
croissance un emploi de la maîtrise des
prix et de la tenue de nos comptes voilà
mesdames et messieurs la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes la transmission de
ce programme de stabilité intervient
donc à un moment charnière puisque ils
marquent l'avènement d'une phase de
normalisation pour nos finances
publiques oui c'est un programme de
normalisation après la parenthèse du
quoi qu'il en coûte durant lequel nous
avons mis en place les amortisseurs
indispensable face à la pandémie la plus
grave depuis un siècle nous sommes
passés du quoi qu'il en coûte ô combien
ça coûte ne nous y trompons pas ce
document est d'ores et déjà décortiqué
par les analystes les investisseurs dans
un contexte j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire en présentant ici le projet de loi
de finances rectificative de tension sur
les rendements de nos obligations
souveraines je rappelle d'ailleurs que
la charge de la dette a bondi de 10,7
milliards d'euros en comptabilité
nationale cette année principalement du
fait de l'inflation et de la remontée
des taux
je sais que sur certains bancs les mots
analystes investisseurs agences de
notation peuvent susciter une forme de
rejet ou de circonspection oui certains
peuvent admettre difficilement que la
sixième puissance mondiale doivent
intégrer la contrainte des taux
d'intérêt et la pression qu'elle exerce
à cela je veux répondre deux choses la
première c'est que tout état aussi
puissant soit il doit composer avec
cette réalité dès lors qu'il est
confronté à un besoin de financement
structurel la deuxième c'est que la
bonne manière d'appréhender le sujet ça
n'est pas d'entretenir le mythe du non
remboursement c'est de faire le choix de
tenir nos comptes il n'y a ni
indépendance ni capacité d'action sans
des finances maîtrisez donc toutes
celles et ceux qui défendent la
souveraineté devrait soutenir la
trajectoire responsables que nous
présentons aujourd'hui oui ce programme
de stabilité traduit d'abord l'objectif
qui est le nôtre en matière de maîtrise
des comptes publics le chemin que nous
empruntons doit nous permettre de
ramener le déficit public sous le seuil
des 3% à l'horizon 2027 corrélativement
le poids de la dette publique dans le
pipe commenceraient à décroître à
compter de 2026 je le disais au début de
mon propos ce programme n'est pas
seulement une feuille de route pour nos
finances publiques c'est le cadre macro
économique dans lequel nous allons
évoluer et qui doit nous permettre
d'atteindre nos objectifs
ces objectifs ils sont clairs protéger
les français face à la hausse des prix
de l'énergie tout en menant des réformes
d'ampleur pour soutenir la croissance
accélérer la transition écologique et
atteindre le plein emploi je rappelle
encore une fois que le plein emploi est
aujourd'hui à portée de main c'est une
situation que notre pays n'a pas connu
depuis le choc pétrolier de 1973
vous l'avez compris ce programme de
stabilité qui se confond d'ailleurs avec
la durée du quinquennat intègre
logiquement les mesures annoncées par le
président de la république au cours de
la campagne électorale je pense aux
mesures en faveur du pouvoir d'achat des
français que j'ai évoqué que nous avons
discuté encore longuement cette nuit aux
mesures en faveur de la compétitivité de
nos entreprises c'est par exemple le cas
de la suppression de la cvae et de la
baisse des impôts de production qui
interviendra nous l'espérons dès 2023
très clairement et c'est un principe
intangible nous n'augmenterons pas les
impôts durant les cinq prochaines années
la soutenabilité des finances publiques
ne doit pas se faire au travers d'
efforts supplémentaires demandés par
l'impôt aux français dans les cinq
prochaines années il n'y aura pas de
hausse généralisée des prélèvements
obligatoires
alors comment allons nous faire pour
mettre en oeuvre les engagements du
président de la république tout en
garantissant la soutenabilité de nos
finances publiques
d'abord en maîtrisant l'augmentation de
la dépense dans toutes ses sphères je
veux rappeler que ce programme de
stabilité intègre une hausse de la
dépense publique de 0 6% en volume sur
la période 2023 2027 je veux souligner
qu'il s'agit de l'augmentation de la
dépense publique la plus faible depuis
20 ans ce qui atteste de notre
détermination à tenir nos comptes
publics elles celles et ceux qui
dénoncent un agenda caché fait de coupes
brutales ou de réductions d'effectifs
massives j'oppose le démenti le plus
catégorique nous ne réduisons pas à la
dépense nous gérons le rythme de son
augmentation en clair nous faisons en
sorte que la sorte que la dépense
publique augmente moins vite que la
richesse que nous créons
pour tenir l'objectif d'augmentation
annuelle de la dépense publique de 0 6%
en moyenne il faut que l'effort soit
réparti entre l'état les collectifs et
locales et la sécurité sociale
concrètement cela doit se traduire par
une baisse en volume de 0 4% sur la
norme de dépense pilotable de l'état de
0 5% sur les dépenses de fonctionnement
des collectivités locales mais durant
cette période nous faisons un choix si
la norme de dépense de l'état va baisser
en volume les dépenses de fonctionnement
des collectivités locales doivent aussi
être maîtrisée en volume nous faisons le
choix de permettre aux dépenses des
administrations de sécurité sociale de
continuer à augmenter de l'ordre de 0 6%
par an preuve de la priorité absolue qui
est la nôtre en matière de santé le
gouvernement à l'occasion d'exposer de
manière détaillée
l'ensemble des mesures mises en oeuvre
pour assurer cette stratégie lors de la
présentation de la nouvelle loi de
programmation des finances publiques que
je vous présenterai en septembre
prochain
concernant la croissance j'ai déjà dit
un mot de la bonne nouvelle s'agissant
des chiffres du deuxième trimestre et de
notre capacité à atteindre l'objectif de
2 5% fixé pour cette année par la suite
la croissance serait de 1 4% en 2023 tu
accélères reste sur la période 2000 24
2027 passant de 1,6 à 1,8 pour cent
entre 2024 et 2027 en 2023 le rebond
plan géopolitique et les tensions côté
offre mais soutenu par les mesures de
soutien au pouvoir d'achat il serait
plus marquée à partir de 2024 et
s'accélère est donc jusqu'en 2027 pour
s'établir à 1 7% en moyenne sur la
période 2000 24 2027 bien entendu ces
chiffres sont et c'est le cas pour
chaque exercice de prévision soumis à
des aléas et les chocs que nous avons
subies ces dernières années je pense
évidemment à la crise sanitaire ou à la
guerre en europe nous invite bien sûr à
la plus grande humilité je sais que
certaines réserves ont été formulées
s'agissant de nos prévisions de
croissance mais je tiens à leur dire
devant vous celles ci sont solides
crédible et étayé je relève d'abord
d'ailleurs qu'elles sont presque
identique à celle dégagée par les
économistes dans le cadre du consensus
forecast qui prévoit 2 3% cette année et
1,3 pour cent l'an prochain la
commission européenne prévoyant quant à
elle une croissance d'1 4% l'an prochain
dans sa dernière prévision de la mi
juillet c'est exactement la prévision
que nous prévoyons je rappelle également
que le fc eux on ne peut pas classer une
proximité avec ce gouvernement où cette
maj majorité que le fc le prévoit un
taux de croissance pour 2027 supérieur à
celui que nous prévoyons nous mêmes
puisque nous prévoyons 1 8% en 2027 là
où l'ouest et prévoit 1 9% en 2027
s'agissant de la trajectoire pour nos
finances publiques je me permets d'y
revenir rapidement pour rappeler les
derniers points de passage comme j'ai
d'ailleurs eu l'occasion de le faire
lors de l'examen du projet de loi de
règlement après un creusement du déficit
public en 2020 à 8 9% du pib en raison
de la déflagration sanitaires ce dernier
s'est amélioré en 2021 pour atteindre
6,4 pour cent du pib' s'agissant de la
dette publique son niveau s'est établi à
112 5 % du pib' l'année dernière il
s'agit d'une hausse de 15 points par
rapport à 2010 9 mai d'une baisse de
plus de 2 points par rapport à 2020 en
2022 le ratio d'endettement devrait
baisser légèrement malgré les mesures
visant à protéger les français du
contexte inflationniste du fait
notamment de la poursuite de la
croissance et atteindrait 100 11 9%
je n'y ai je n'ignore pas là non plus
les réserves qui ont pu être formulées
concernant notre trajectoire de maîtrise
comte je veux simplement rappeler que
jusqu'ici nous avons tenu nos objectifs
nous avons réduit le déficit public de
2,5 points de pipe l'année dernière et
nous tiendrons la cible de 5% cette
année inchangé depuis la loi de finances
initial voté à l'automne dernier parce
que nous aurons une croissance conforme
à notre prévision cela a été confirmé
par l'insee il y a quelques jours parce
que l'impact budgétaire des mesures que
nous avons mises en place pour soutenir
le pouvoir d'achat est en grande partie
compensée par les économies réalisées
sur les charges de service public de
l'énergie et parce que nous pouvons
compter sur un surplus de recettes
fiscales liées à l'exceptionnelle rebond
de l'économie française l'année dernière
sur la période 2023 2027 le gouvernement
s'est fixé pour objectif de retour à des
comptes publiques maîtriser c'est la
normalisation que j'évoquais le début de
mon propos le déficit devrait revenir
sous le seuil des 3% à l'horizon 2027
grâce à un ajustement structurel de 0,3
point de pib par an à compter de 2024
cela doit conduire à une décrue du ratio
dette publique/pib à compter de 2026
cette maîtrise des finances publiques ne
fait en aucun cas obstacles aux
investissements indispensables pour
assurer la transition écologique et
numériques atteindre le plein emploi et
s'assurer de la compétitivité de nos
entreprises je rappelle tout à l'heure
la suppression à venir de la cvae cette
trajectoire s'inscrit en cohérence avec
les plans france relance et france 2030
qui permettront de soutenir l'activité
le potentiel de croissance en accélérant
la transition écologique en favorisant
l'investissement l'innovation la
cohésion sociale et territoriale et en
assurant la souveraineté numérique et
industriels vous le voyez ce programme
est un cadre pas un carcan c'est le
cadre dans lequel
nous avons fixé une ambition c'est le
cadre que nous avons fixée c'est le
cadre dans lequel nous agissons et je
l'espère dans lequel nous réussirons
notre conviction c'est que des finances
publiques maîtriser c'est la condition
sinequanone d'une action efficace au
service des français c'est la condition
sinequanone d'un pays qui garde sa
liberté nous aurons l'occasion
d'échanger à nouveau sur tous ces enjeux
à l'automne lors de la présentation de
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques et nous aurons bien sûr
l'occasion d'en échanger dès cet après
midi à l'occasion de ce débat je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à présent à monsieur jean françois
husson rapporteur général de la
commission des finances vous avez dix
minutes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
avec trois mois de retard nous nous
retrouvons aujourd'hui pour débattre du
programme de stabilité que le
gouvernement s'apprête à transmettre aux
institutions européennes et qui décrit
donc le scénario macroéconomique et la
trajectoire des finances publiques pour
la période 2000 22 2027 en effet il doit
selon les règles communautaires être
transmis avant la fin du mois d'avril
lorsque le gouvernement a indiqué son
souhait d'attendre la fin de la période
des élections présidentielles pour le
faire il s'agissait déjà d'une décision
assez surprenante et inhabituelle avec
le présent claude raynal nous sommes
inquiétés alors et nous avons demandé si
et quand il serait présenté il devait
arriver bientôt puis début juin puis
après l'élection législative puis début
juillet enfin début août nous y sommes
il est là mais pourquoi donc un tel
retard pourquoi avoir eu besoin de trois
mois supplémentaires pour présenter ce
programme de stabilité
certains penseraient que le gouvernement
aurait pu vouloir cacher aux électeurs
le temps des législatives ces véritables
ambitions et son programme pour le
redressement des finances publiques
toutefois pour que cette hypothèse
tienne il aurait fallu que le programme
de stabilité témoigne effectivement
d'une ambition et comporte un programme
pour la consolidation des finances
publiques or dans ce document vous ne
trouverez ni l'un ni l'autre pour
commencer le programme de stabilité
retrace un scénario macroéconomique qui
me paraît pour le moins optimistes
prévisions de croissance du pib en
volume pour 2022 deux ennemis et pour
2023 de +14 j'aimerais jouer sur ce
point des bonnes nouvelles je les dis
annoncée par l'insee la semaine dernière
indiquant que l'activité a augmenté de
0.5 % au second semestre de cette année
alors qu'elle s'était contractée au
premier trimestre néanmoins j'observe
que ce résultat s'explique surtout par
la diminution de nos importations en
raison de la hausse des prix et d'un
tourisme s est heureux plus dynamique
que prévu
si la prévision de croissance pour 2022
me semble raisonnable sous réserve que
le contexte international ne se dégrade
pas ces retenues pour 2023 ma part est
en revanche optimistes notamment quand
le fmi l'évaluent seulement à un point
pour les années 2000 24 à 2027 j'ai le
sentiment que le scénario de croissance
du pib' est à ce stade très au dessus de
ce que nous pouvons sérieusement
attendre imaginez d'après les prévisions
du gouvernement
le pipe devrait augmenter en volume de
12,6 pour cent entre 2021 et 2027 alors
que dans le scénario du fmi ce serait
seulement 9,4 points l'écart excusez du
peu c'est 45 milliards il est probable
que cette surévaluation de la croissance
économique soit lié partiellement à une
prévision trop optimiste
quant à l'évolution du taux de chômage
avec seulement 5 2% de chômeurs en 2027
d'après les données du programme de
stabilité là où le fmi prévoit plutôt
7,4 pour cent
les hypothèses du programme de stabilité
concernant l'écart de production me
paraissent décalé par rapport à la
réalité observée de notre économie en
effet le gouvernement estime que notre
économie évoluera au moins jusqu'en 2023
près d'un point de pourcentage en
dessous de son niveau potentiel
c'est d'abord une hypothèse très
attendent pour qui sait combien
actuellement nos entreprises peinent à
recruter ce qui implique généralement
que l'économie a atteint ses propres
limites
c'est ensuite une hypothèse qui permet
d'anticiper des taux de croissance plus
fort puisque un écart de production
négatif est important signal que
l'économie bénéficie d'un fort potentiel
de rebond c'est enfin est aussi une
hypothèse qui n'est pas partagé par le
fce ainsi la commission européenne
estime qu'en 2023 l'économie évoluera
déjà au niveau de son niveau potentiel
la capacité de rebond prévu pour le
programme de stabilité quasiment tout au
long de la période 2000 22-27
s'expliquerait donc non seulement par
l'hypothèse d'un écart de production
négatif très important en 2022 mais
surtout par une prévision de croissance
potentielle de 1 35% qui me paraît
surestimé j'observe d'ailleurs que
d'après le gouvernement la croissance
potentielle serait principalement
soutenue par certaines réformes du
marché du travail et de l'emploi réforme
des retraites et de l'assurance chômage
par exemple or pour l'essentiel le
contour de ces réformes est loin d'être
défini est me semble-t-il elles vont
mettre du temps pour être voté ainsi la
prévision de croissance potentielle
retenu par le gouvernement ne m'apparaît
pas raisonnable
pourtant comme l'a justement relevé le
haut conseil des finances publiques ces
hypothèses sont très optimistes
si l'on tient compte du fait que la
demande de biens et services de nos
partenaires pourraient progressé moins
rapidement qu'anticipé et que le
resserrement de la politique monétaire
et des conditions de financement des
agents devraient au contraire
ralentir la progression des
investissements
au final le scénario macroéconomique du
programme de stabilité repose sur des
hypothèses que je qualifie de précaires
et qui sont peu détaillé en tout état de
cause c'est sur ce scénario
macroéconomique qui est construit la
trajectoire des construite par dont la
trajectoire des finances publiques
retenu par le gouvernement alors que
peut-on dire pour commencer je dirais
qu'elle est peut-être les plus
ambitieuses en effet les dépenses
publique atteindrait environ 1600 75
milliards d'euros en 2027 soit une
augmentation hors mesures de soutien
face à la crise sanitaire à l'inflation
de plus de 250 milliards apportés à 2022
on peut relever que le gouvernement
s'engage à ne laisser progresser les
dépenses publiques en volume que 2 0 6%
en moyenne en pratique cet effort ne
concernera que les seules années 2000 24
à 2027 puisque les dépenses publiques
neutraliser des mesures de soutien face
à la crise sanitaire et à l'inflation
progressons en 2023 de plus trois et
demi pour cent ainsi rapporté à
l'ensemble du quinquennat l'effort
consenti consistera en une croissance
moyenne en volume des dépenses publiques
ordinaire de l'ordre de 1 2% par an et
non de 0 6% on peut donc observer
également qu'il propose de faire peser
les efforts sur la seconde moitié du
quinquennat plutôt que sur le début ce
qui ne manque pas de surprendre parce
qu'on sait on sait les uns les autres
que c'est en début de quinquennat que
les mesures les plus volontaires
éventuellement les plus difficiles à
prendre doivent être prises et au final
avec un effort aussi limiter notre
déficit public refluera assez lentement
et ne reviendrait en dessous de 3% du
pic en 2027 et encore s'il y arrive de
0,1 point notre endettement public
continuerait de s'accroître et ne
refluerait qu'en 2027 pour revenir au
même niveau que l'année dernière
c'est-à-dire
112 5 points de pipe
cette trajectoire monsieur le ministre
manque aussi de réalisme aucune
documentation n'accompagne ne
l'accompagnent ainsi d'après les
estimations faites la trajectoire de
dépenses du gouvernement représenterait
une économie d'environ 45 milliards
d'euros en 2000 27 par rapport à un
scénario à législation inchangée et donc
au delà de la réforme des retraites
régulièrement mis en avant par le
gouvernement alors qu'elle ne produira
pas d'effets budgétaire à court terme je
relève qu'une bonne part des économies
attendues pourraient
réaliser être réalisées sur les dépenses
de chômage celle-ci ne représenteraient
d'ailleurs plus que 1 2% du pub en 2022
et
0,9 pour cent en 2027 là où elles sont
beaucoup plus élevés dans la période 95
2019 s'agirait donc d'une maîtrise que
je qualifierais considérable des
dépenses de chômage obtenue à la faveur
d'une forte décote du cru du chômage
puisque vous envisagez qu'il serait à
5,2 points en 2027
mais le gouvernement à ce jour n'a
fourni aucune explication sur les moyens
permettant d'atteindre cette cible en
matière d'emploi alors je le dis
clairement revendiqué un objectif global
d'économie des dépenses publiques dans
la réalisation repose sur des
perspectives d'évolution du marché de
l'emploi aussi fragile que celle retenue
par le gouvernement ne me paraît pas ce
stade sérieux mes chers collègues je
prends acte aujourd'hui du fait que le
gouvernement s'est contenté du service
minimum pour construire ce programme de
stabilité en retenant des hypothèses
macroéconomiques et de maîtrise des
dépenses que je qualifie peu crédible
j'espère très sincèrement comme il ya
invité le haut conseil des finances
publiques que le gouvernement fera
preuve de davantage de sérieux dans la
préparation de la loi de programmation
des finances publiques attendu pour cet
automne celle ci devra notamment
d'écrire les moyens que le gouvernement
entend mobiliser pour réduire la dépense
de l'état de 0 4% en volume et celle des
collectivités locales de 0 5% en volume
également en moyenne et jusqu'à la fin
du quinquennat j'espère tout aussi
sincèrement que les engagements de
maîtrise des dépenses qui figureront
seront plus ambitieux mais surtout plus
crédible et mieux documenté que ceux
figurant dans ce programme de stabilité
alors même que nous assistons à un
changement de régime dans le financement
notre endettement public nous avons
l'obligation de démontrer notre sérieux
au plan budgétaire enfin et pour
conclure je rappelle que toutes les
économies des années que les
administrations publiques seront
dégagées sont autant de ressources que
nous pourrons mobiliser pour engager la
réduction de la dette écologique qui
préoccupe et à juste titre les jeunes
générations et à vrai dire tous les
français c'est assurément un défi que
nous devons relever ensemble je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur général je
passe la parole à présent monsieur
claude raynal président de la commission
des finances vous avez cinq minutes
monsieur le président
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur l'important général
chers collègues nous vivons des temps
politique extraordinaire il y à peu
certains étaient diabolisés en raison de
leur supposée désobéissance aux règles
européennes
et aujourd'hui surprise ce sont ceux là
même qui se présentait comme le héros de
la doxa européenne qui se permettent de
désobéir à ces règles le gouvernement
nous présente en effet ce programme de
stabilité qui aurait dû être transmis à
la commission européenne fin avril et
que l'on ne me dise pas que c'est à
cause des élections présidentielles en
2012 comme en 2017 ces élections
n'avaient pourtant pas empêché la
présentation par les gouvernements
sortants dudit programme
circonstance aggravante nous nous
retrouvons pour en débattre au début du
mois d'août dont on conviendra que c'est
une période particulièrement peu
favorable à un débat parlementaire
approfondie comme pour les autres textes
des finances publiques vous avez fait le
choix de retarder le calendrier à
l'extrême ce qui n'est absolument pas
satisfaisant quelques indiscrétions
concordantes rapportées par la presse
nous indique cependant que vous auriez
demandé à votre administration de tordre
quelque peu les chiffres pour que ceci
soit raccord avec votre discours ceci
explique peut-être cela que dire qui
plus est de l'information transmise par
vous à la presse plus de dix jours avant
le parlement mettant celui ci dans
l'impossibilité de répondre aux
affirmations souvent péremptoires du
gouvernement c'est une méthode
réellement inadmissible ce point étant
rappelé je voudrais dire combien ce
document peut laisser perplexe comme
d'ailleurs cela transparaît dans la vie
très réservé du haut conseil des
finances publiques bien sûr nous avons
l'habitude la commission européenne
aussi malheureusement que le programme
de stabilité français soient optimistes
peu crédible
renvoyant régulièrement les mesures les
plus difficiles pour la fin de la
période père prieur d'y croire la
relecture du programme
2018-2022 de ce point de vue ne manque
pas de sel mais il faut dire que la
crise du gilet jaune la pandémie
une hyène était sauf peut-être pour la
première difficilement prévisibles
cependant la leçon devrait nous servir
l'ampleur des incertitudes géopolitiques
et macroéconomiques de vendre
semble-t-il nous inciter à davantage de
prudence ou à tout le moins à présenter
des scénarios plus et il revient pas sur
les chiffres ont été donnés tout à
l'heure par le rapporteur général
mais je ne peux que souligner
l'existence d'aléas très négatifs comme
les qualifs et le haut-conseil baisse de
la croissance en allemagne constitue
crâne difficultés de la chine nous les
connaissons je doute aussi que votre
scénario intègre l'effet récessif des
mesures de ralentissement de la dépense
publique que par ailleurs vous
préconisez selon vos termes vous
prévoyez une augmentation en volume de
la dépense publique la plus faible
depuis 20 ans en raison du contexte
politique et social
cela ne me semble ni raisonnable ni
réaliste d'autant plus que ce scénario
ça a été dit n'est pas très étayé vous
en reste et a des objectifs très
généraux et qui peuvent être d'ailleurs
partagé par tous la priorisation des
dépenses d'avenir qui peut être contre
la réduction des dépenses inefficiente
hockey pour les administrations
publiques locales les modalités de leurs
contributions sont pour le moins
nébuleuses les administrations de
sécurité sociale devront participer à
l'effort avec la poursuite de la
transformation du système de santé dont
on ne mesure pas bien les effets en
termes d'économie les stades
dispositions concrètes cités sont les
réformes des retraites et de l'assurance
chômage
concernant la réforme des retraites
difficile de dire que cette réforme qui
d'ailleurs à l'origine n'est pas être
une mesure d'économie budgétaire mais
une simple mesure d'équité pourrait
rapporter rapidement des recettes
concernant l'assurance chômage vous
tablez sur une amélioration durable du
marché du travail nous l'espérons pouces
mais sincèrement sur quel fondement
cette prévision optimiste repose tête
concernant les recettes vous annoncer
une poursuite des baisses d'impôts
tourner cette fois vers les seules
entreprises au nom d'une politique de
l'offre qui viendra encore une fois
fragilisé davantage nos finances
publiques je doute fort que le problème
de compétitivité de nos entreprises
relèvent enfin avant tout fiscale vous
évoquez la remise en cause de niches
fiscales sociales peu efficaces mais
sans aucune illustration ni chiffrage
bresse vous ne dites rien quoi qu'il en
soit il me semble plus que jamais
nécessaire de consolider nos recettes
fiscales pour financer les politiques
publiques dans notre pays a besoin et
notamment vos dépenses d'investissement
j'espère donc que la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
précisera une trajectoire des finances
publiques aujourd'hui pour tout dire à
peine ébauchés et au fond en l'état peu
crédible finalement monsieur le ministre
votre feuille de route budgétaire
ressemblent furieusement plus à une mise
en garde de vos collègues des dépensiers
du gouvernement qu à une proposition
sérieuse transmise à la commission
européenne et aux parlementaires je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le président enfin la
parole est à monsieur philippe moullier
vice président de la commission des
affaires sociales
[Applaudissements]
vous avez cinq minutes chers collègues
on joue c'est madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le plan de
la commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
nous voici donc tardivement réunis afin
d'examiner un programme de stabilité qui
aurait dû nous est soumis en avril je
consacrerai naturellement propos aux
administrations de sécurité sociale qui
comme vous l'indiquez dans le rapport
monsieur le ministre représente la
moitié des dépenses publiques
s'agissant des constats ce programme
souligne ce que la commission des
affaires sociales a déjà pu observer par
elle même après un exercice 2009 un
extraordinaire à tous égards les
dépenses de la sécurité sociale street
au sus à commencer par celles de la
branche maladie ou encore crû fortement
en 2021 et la hausse restera
significative en 2022 seul un bond
spectaculaire des recettes
principalement sous l'effet de
l'évolution de la masse salariale a
permis de contenir quelque peu les
déficits à un niveau cependant très
élevé 24 milliards d'euros en 2020 tiers
en revanche je me réjouis de
l'amélioration de la situation
financière de l'assurance chômage en
espérant que sera durable et qu'elle
permettra au régime de retrouver un
niveau d'endettement supportable
pour l'avenir de façon assez
traditionnel le programme de stabilité
dessine une trajectoire financière
optimiste qui demande à être vérifiée
notamment pour ce qui concerne
l'accélération de la croissance que vous
anticipez à partir de 2024 de ce fait
prises dans leur ensemble les
administrations de sécurité sociale
retrouverait une capacité de financement
dès 2022 leur excédent global atteignant
même 1 nul 3 % du pib en fin de période
j'en prends acte néanmoins je tiens à
souligner que les dernières lois de
finances de sécurité sociale dessiner
une trajectoire financière bien plus
sombre a priori incompatibles avec les
stations de la dette de la sécurité
sociale avant fin 2030 trois comme
l'imposent d'ailleurs la loi organique
en vigueur quant à la stratégie de
sortie de crise monsieur le ministre le
retard de quatre mois de ce programme de
stabilité n'a hélas pas permis au
gouvernement de présenter au parlement
les grands choix qui nous permettront de
revenir à une trajectoire financière
plus équilibré tout juste est-il précisé
que la maîtrise des dépenses publiques
repose principalement sur des réformes
structurelles contact notamment la
réforme des retraites vous indiquez
ensuite que le gouvernement aura
l'occasion d'exposer de manière
détaillée l'ensemble des mesures mises
en oeuvre pour assurer des stratégies à
l'automne lors de l'élaboration de la
nouvelle loi de programmation des
finances publiques nous continuons donc
d'attendre
pourriez vous monsieur ministre
cependant nous préciser le calendrier de
présentation de ce texte voire dès à
présent le niveau d'économies que vous
attendez d'une réforme des retraites
également fortement sollicité
mon dernier mot sera pour souligner que
le programme de stabilité revient assez
longuement sur les évolutions du cadre
organique des lois de finances le
gouvernement y voit un outil qui
permettra au pam allemand de mieux
contrôler les finances publiques je me
permet très simplement de vous rappeler
monsieur le ministre que le cadre
organique des lois de financement de la
sécurité sociale changera aussi dès
septembre grâce à l'entrée en vigueur de
la loi organique du 14 mars 2002 et bien
que ce texte n'est pas repris les
propositions les plus ambitieuses du
sénat il devrait permettre si nous le
faisons vivre d'améliorer le contrôle
parlementaire sur les finances sociales
notamment au travers d'une clause
importante la clause de retour au
parlement en cas de dérapage en cours
d'exercice
il reviendra à chacun d'entre nous de
nous emparer de ces outils en premier
lieu monsieur le ministre le
gouvernement devra se départir de l'idée
solidement ancrées et encore vérifié en
2020 et 2021 que dès lors que c'est la
sécurité sociale qui paye le
gouvernement fait ce qu'il veut en
dehors de tout contrôle parlementaire
nous comptons sur vous pour faire
évoluer cette culture et je vous
remercie pour votre attention
merci monsieur le président dans la
suite du débat la parole est aux
orateurs des groupes j'appelle à
monsieur patrice joly du groupe
socialiste
douze minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ce
programme de stabilité arrive avec
plusieurs mois de retard s'était dit
avant moi et nous est transmise dans un
délai qui frise l'irrespect des débats
parlementaires même si rien ne vous
oblige quel mauvais signal en ce début
de mandature nous y mettons déjà
habitués sous le précédent quinquennat
mais nous avions un peu d'espoir puisque
nous pensions avoir compris que le
gouvernement voulait favoriser le
dialogue avec les parlementaires
monsieur le ministre nous disait il y a
encore une semaine combien il était
important de laisser le parlement
travailler en amont sur les textes
visiblement cela reste pour l'instant un
vécu et sur le fond ce document soulève
des interrogations due notamment à
l'insuffisance des informations fournies
ainsi on comprend que la stratégie
gouvernementale se fonde sur une
réduction de la dette à dater de 2026 et
sur un passage sous la barre des 3% du
déficit en 2027
près prévisions mises en doute par le
fce monsieur le ministre et selon vos
prévisions ces trois pour cent serait
atteint grâce à une maîtrise de
l'augmentation de la dépense publique de
0 6% par an au regard du contexte
économique et sociale d'une part et
d'autre part de la dynamique naturelle
de la dépense publique comment allez
vous vous y prendre
nous sommes en droit de rejoindre
l'analyse du haut conseil des finances
publiques qui parle d'une trajectoire de
finances publiques qui s'appuie sur une
prévision de croissance un peu trop
optimiste sur des réductions des
dépenses à ce stade non documentés par
une description précise des réformes et
des mesures en dépenses tout d'abord sur
vos prévisions de croissance trop
optimistes
à contre-courant des prévisions de la
direction générale du trésor du fmi de
l'oscd eux la banque de france vous
avancez une croissance de 1,6 pour cent
en 2007 en sous-entendant qu'elle
découlera de la réforme des réformes des
retraites de la baisse des impôts sur la
production des réformes du marché du
travail de la formation du chômage durée
ça mais aussi de la poursuite des
dépenses des plans de relance et france
2003 mais la réalité sera tout autre
monsieur le ministre la cure de stries
d'austérité que vous allez faire vivre
aux français avec une baisse continue
des dépenses publiques en valeur réelle
notamment pour le financement des
services publics et l'insuffisance des
revalorisations des dispositifs sociaux
ne pourra générer une croissance molle
que vous avez d'ailleurs évalué et crée
une insécurité pour nos concitoyens
atteints dans leur pouvoir d'achat dans
ces conditions permettez-nous d'alors
d'avoir de sérieux doutes quant à vos
capacités atteindre le plein emploi et
des interrogations sur l'accélération
nécessaire de la transition écologique
sur votre réduction des dépenses il est
très clair que des prévisions manque et
des précisions cruellement
pourtant nous le savons qu'une hausse
des dépenses en volume est prévue pour
financer le ségur de la santé le plan
pital le plan urgence pourquoi n'avons
nous pas de chiffres précis
quid du financement du cinquième puisque
aujourd'hui totalement disparu des
radars dont on connaît pourtant l'impact
budgétaire pour nos collectivités nous
n'êtes pas sans savoir qu'elles sont
tant qu'elles ont une obligation de
gestion équilibrée de leur budget je
tiens à attirer votre attention sur le
fait qu'elles sont d'une part
pourvoyeuse de service public souvent en
compensation du retrait de l'état sur
les territoires et qu'elles réalisent
d'autre part 70% de l'investissement
public vous prévoyez qu'elles seront de
nouveau associé à l'effort de maîtrise
de la dépense publique attention à ne
rien brisé ensuite vous vantez dans ce
document les bons résultats obtenus en
termes de niveau de chômage vous avez un
art certain d'enjoliver la réalité il
faut mettre cette baisse en relation
avec une augmentation des dispositifs
conduisant à une sortie de chômage
notamment les contrats en alternance ou
les contrats d'apprentissage il ne faut
pas oublier que le chômage des jeunes
15-24 ans et 3,3 fois supérieur à celui
des plus de 50 ans aujourd'hui avec 5,4
millions de personnes le chômage en
france restent à des niveaux élevés ce
n'est pas rien enfin
on compte 1,9 million de personnes
exclues des chiffres du chômage car
elles sont inactives malgré leur souhait
de travailler de plus monsieur le
ministre beaucoup de nos concitoyens
n'ont désormais pas d'autre choix que de
recourir de plus en plus à des emplois
précaires ou un statut non sécurisés
tels quant aux entrepreneurs
travailleurs rue maryse et personnel en
cdt nous sommes en droit de vous
demander quel avenir se dessine pour eux
d'une manière générale vous ne pouvez
pas évacuer la question de l'explosion
de la paupérisation de nos concitoyens
la crise à l'été a augmenté d'un million
le nombre de pauvres de notre pays qui
représentent désormais 14 6% de la
population ce qui explique selon un
rapport du secours catholique que sept
millions de français ont eu recours à
l'aide alimentaire en 2021 à l'autre
bout de la chaîne au contraire une
petite élite peut s'estimer très
satisfaite de votre politique car c'est
pour elle que vous guérard nez depuis
maintenant cinq ans en cinq ans emmanuel
macron ainsi supprimé 80 milliards
d'euros de recettes fiscales pérennes
les commentateurs économiques insistent
beaucoup sur le quoi qu'il en coûte des
dépenses du président il ne faudra pas
oublier désormais d'y ajouter le quoi
qu'on en perde des recettes car en même
temps vous réduisez la pelle pour les
ménages et vous réduisiez les
prélèvements obligatoires pour les
détenteurs de capital suppression de
l'impôt sur la solidarité sur la fortune
création d'exceet taxe plafonnement de
l'impôt sur les revenus du capital
soient moins de 4 milliards d'euros par
an de cadeaux à ces catégories sociales
à cela s'ajoute la baisse de la taxe
d'habitation y compris pour les 20% les
plus riches qui en deux ans a coûté
quelques 10,7 milliards d'euros aux
recettes publiques sans oublier la
baisse de 10 milliards d'euros des
impôts de production à quelques ainsi
que la baisse de l'impôt sur les
sociétés
cette baisse de la fiscalité est
compréhensible lors qu'il faudra faire
contribuer les plus riches et en
particulier ceux qui profitent des
différentes crises récentes sanitaire
géopolitique et autres en définitive
rien de nouveau dans ce programme de
stabilité qui pourrait créer l'espoir
un monde d'après si la crise sanitaire a
fait exploser les budgets gonfler la
dette le cap demeure le même pas de
contreparties aux aides de l'état pas de
mise à contribution des plus riches à
l'effort national pire malgré le ségur
on continue à fermer des lits d'hôpitaux
car le paradigme gestionnaires à courte
vue perdure de même la crise sanitaire
mondiale la crise la guerre en ukraine
les tensions sur les prix de l'énergie
l'inflation qui croit tout ce cocktail a
révélé la nécessité d'un changement de
politique de grande envergure nous
n'avons plus le choix nous devons
désormais nous prémunir contre les
crises à venir et protéger les plus
vénérables d'entre nous il nous faudra
atténuer voire résoudre les crises
qu'elles soient sociales économiques
écologiques et résorber les inégalités
qui fragilisent la cohésion sociale et
la démocratie
il n'est plus tenable de faire en même
temps des cadeaux fiscaux aux plus
riches et prétendent vouloir soutenir
les plus démunis avec des primes ou des
baisses éphémère de quelques centimes à
la pompe le ruissellement ne fonctionne
pas et la loi du marché ne réduit pas
les inégalités
lors de son discours de politique
générale la première ministre elisabeth
borne à demander d'arrêter de croire
qu'à chaque problème la solution était
une taxe on lui retard louis roth arte
rétorquera pardon excusez ma volontiers
il serait également bon que le
gouvernement arrête de penser qu'à
chaque problème la solution est une
baisse d'impôts un état fort est un état
capable d'agir grâce à des marges de
manoeuvre budgétaires importantes issues
des recettes fiscales nous avons besoin
de ces recettes pour lancer le plan
grand âge renforcer davantage l'hôpital
ou encore financer les dépenses de
retraite et de santé répondre aux
besoins d'éducation de la recherche
ainsi qu'à la transition écologique et
l'adaptation aux changements qu'il est
climatique sans oublier les dépenses
d'investissements nécessaires pour
accroître notre sécurité économique et
sauf a tué nos services publics et à
décourager définitivement ceux qui
voulaient y travailler et y croient pas
en soignant aux enseignants il faudra
bien à améliorer leurs conditions de
travail et leur rémunération
la dynamique la dynamique structurelle
les économies riches va historiquement
dans le sens de plus grande dépense
publique que faisons nous des recettes
existe avec le rétablissement de l'usf
la création d'une tranche supplémentaire
de l'impôt sur le revenu et la
suppression de la flat tax
l'augmentation des services nul des
taxes sur les services numériques dite
taxe gars femmes à cela on peut ajouter
la lutte plus sévères contre les
pratiques de fraude fiscale évaluée
selon le syndicat solidaires des
finances a plus de ça près de 100
milliards d'euros mais d'autres
solutions encore existe au plan européen
il nous faut des jarres définir un cadre
budgétaire et monétaire européen durable
et rebâtir nos politiques à la hauteur
des enjeux qui sont devant nous à cet
égard une question devient de plus en
plus prégnante celle des ressources
propres l'adaptation l'adoption de la
taxe de 15% sur les multinationales est
actuellement bloqué par un veto hongrois
mais il peut être plus tueur mais par
une procédure de coopération renforcée
entre pays volontaires mettant en place
de manière individuelle et concertée
cette taxation d'autres ressources
peuvent être mobilisés le scandale des
panamas peppers a révélé les onze mille
300 milliards de dollars placés dans des
paradis fiscaux ce qui nous rappelle
l'urgence pour les états membres de
coopérer entre eux afin de renforcer la
transparence et ainsi mettre un terme à
ses pratiques fiscales dommageables un
système fiscal plus équitable à
l'échelle européenne est un impératif
pour mieux lutter contre les inégalités
en matière de revenus et de richesses il
devient essentiel de franchir le pas
vers une fiscalité coming il est
désormais temps de mettre en place une
imposition commune sur les bénéfices des
sociétés de conclure les négociations
pour une taxe sur les transactions
financières d'ici 2026 enfin nous devons
revenir sur ces règles budgétaires
européennes
référentiel 3% et 60% du blick qui sont
incompatibles avec cette urgence à
investir massivement et dont on se
demande toujours sur quoi ces règles
sont fondées leur suspension pendant la
période de pandémie est révélatrice leur
quine des d'équations aux défis et crise
que doit surmené surmonter l'union
européenne c'est pourquoi le pacte de
stabilité de croissance doit être mise
en service des mutations économiques
sociales nécessaires à la réussite des
transitions climatique et numérique
engagée dans cette perspective il est
indispensable de dépasser la seule
logique du pib' qui doit être assorti de
nouveaux indicateurs de croissance et de
richesse et de réviser notre approche
conservatrice et libérale de
l'endettement public il n'est pas qu'une
charge mais qui est une des conditions
pour réussir les conditions les
transitions nécessaires qui sont devant
nous pour conclure monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues de grands chantiers
s'offrent à nous mais il suppose au
préalable de réviser nos outils de
coordination économique dont 7 obsolète
programme de stabilité je vous remercie
merci chers collègues j'appelle
maintenant monsieur teva rofritsch du
groupe r des pays pour 8 minutes
madame la présidente je président la
commission des finances puis sur leurs
porteurs général monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
il n'y a pas si longtemps nous étions
habitués à considérer un taux de chômage
dépassant les 10% comme une fatalité
compte de l'injustice le taux de chômage
des femmes a même parfois dépassé les
12%
il n'y a pas si longtemps nous étions
résignés le secteur secondaire
s'effondrer et notre puissance
industrielle semblait destiné à n'être
plus qu'un lointain souvenir
il n'y a pas si longtemps nous pensions
qu'une trajectoire de retour à
l'équilibré ne pourrait être présenté et
qui serait impossible de repasser en
dessous des 3% de déficit public
il n'y a pas si longtemps nous pensions
que l'état de nos finances publiques et
la croissance atone nous londres et
impuissant à affronter les crises qui
pourraient nous frapper et pourtant
autant mes chers collègues le chômage
continue de baisser comme jamais
auparavant
pourtant l'emploi industriel repart avec
un regain de dynamisme entraînée par le
plan de relance et les réformes fiscales
et réglementaires entamé depuis 2010 est
pourtant nous avions réussi à le faire
repasser en dessous des 3% pour la
première fois depuis le début des années
avant bien avant bien entendu qu une
crise mondiale d'une ampleur sans
précédent ne vienne bouleverser nos
efforts et ceux du gouvernement
pourtant nous avons su faire face à la
crise mondiale la plus grave depuis la
dernière guerre mondiale main dans la
main avec nos partenaires européens et
avec un plan de relance imedi tient non
seulement sauvé notre économie de
désastre et le pouvoir d'achat des
français quand même plus progressé sur
la période
mais qui est également remis notre
industrie sur les rails de la
compétitivité est permis de préparer
l'avenir
mais la question de jean ton monte sur
vauban de ce côté-ci de l'hémicycle
c'est pouvant nous sacrifier au présent
notre avenir et celui de nos enfants
à ma gauche j'entends contraire que nous
ne faisons jamais assez
et qu'il ne faut pas laisser la rigueur
imposée ces contraintes aux uns comme
aux autres j'aimerais répondre que la
trajectoire proposé par le gouvernement
porte une vision pour la france qui
répond à la double exigence qui vous
anime en dépit de nos désaccords
elle répondra aux inquiétudes en
préservant le soutien nécessaire de
l'état dans un bon nombre de domaines
tout en présentant une normalisation de
nos finances publiques qui permet de
préserver les générations à venir
il tiendra à notre vigilance de
parlementaires que nous respections cet
engagement nous comptons sur vous tous
chers collègues comme vous pouvez
compter sur nous
même tardif ce débat sur le programme de
stabilité est toujours un moment de
clarté qui nous permet de nous
positionner sur ces questions
essentielles et sur la direction que
nous prendrons
débat redoublera d'importance qu'au
moment de l'examen de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques qui
sera le véritable moment pour nous
parlementaires de nous saisir de ce
sujet notre groupe sera au rendez vous
en attendant nous continuons d'agir dans
cette direction pour soutenir l'emploi
et l'activité économique tout en faisant
face aux impondérables
nous avons voté hier l'augmentation du
plafond des heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées
encourager l'emploi et la croissance
rétablir nos finances publiques soutenir
les plus fragiles c'est ce qui nous
anime depuis 2000 17 et celle équation
délicate que nous aurons à résoudre pour
les années qui viennent
monsieur le ministre vous l'avez rappelé
la dynamique est lancée pour 2022 avec
une croissance de l'activité qui
s'établirait à +2 5% 2022 et un déficit
qui continueraient de se résorber 2,4
pour cent
nous faisons néanmoins encore face à des
tensions comme celle sur le pouvoir
d'achat qui nous réunit c'est tard dans
la nuit ou plutôt tôt ce matin
et prenant chacun de ces sujets à bras
le corps
collectivement nous y faisons face mais
nous devons aussi poursuivre avec raison
et détermination nos efforts
la tâche n'est pas facile mais nous y
arriverons nous le devons à nos
concitoyens et à l'avenir que nous
devons bâtir pour les générations
futures merci de votre attention
merci chers collègues à la parole est à
présent à madame vanina paolig agen du
groupe des indépendants pour 8 minutes
chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
général mes chers collègues
on a beaucoup reproché au gouvernement
d'avoir tardé à publier son programme de
stabilité
c'est une réalité à laquelle il semble
difficile de s'opposer bien qu'on en
comprenne facilement les causes mais là
n'est pas l'essentiel et ce pour au
moins deux raisons
la première c'est que le calendrier
électoral a percuté la procédure
européenne
certes le gouvernement a bénéficié d'une
certaine forme de stabilité notamment à
bercy ce qui aurait pu lui permettre
d'être dans les temps mais on aurait
tort d'ignorer ce qui s'est passé depuis
avril dernier
la majorité présidentielle est désormais
prise en tenaille par deux mâchoires
populiste l'une à l'extrême droite
l'autre à l'extrême gauche
cette configuration commande la prudence
la seconde raison mes chers collègues
c'est qu'au fond nous connaissions déjà
la teneur de ce programme de stabilité
c'est une question de mathématiques de
points ne peuvent être reliés que par
une seule droite autrement dit
connaissant la situation actuelle de nos
comptes soit le point de départ et
connaissant le point d'arrivée
fixé par le gouvernement d'un déficit
inférieur à 3 % du pib en 2027 il n'y a
guère qu'une seule trajectoire
à mes yeux les débats se cristallise
autour d'un seul mot la dette
mais ce mot mes chers collègues peut se
décliner en plusieurs épisodes du vous
en propose quatre il ya notre dette
publique il ya notre dette européenne il
y à la dette privée et il y à la dette
climatique
notre dette publique d'abord c'est
l'indicateur majeur et incontournable
celui qui résume le mieux non pas
simplement la gestion actuelle des
comptes mais aussi et pour beaucoup la
gestion passée c'est aussi le chiffre
qui nous annonce la quantité d'efforts à
fournir dans le futur que ce soit par la
réduction des dépenses ou par les
hausses d'impôts car il faudra bien
ramener les dépenses en deçà des
recettes nous voulons éviter la
banqueroute ce n'est pas là une
obsession osterrieth hermes est une
question de bon sens
l'histoire a montré que les pays qui ne
tiennent pas leur compte sont rarement
ceux qui financent les politiques
sociales ou environnementales les plus
ambitieuses
ce problème n'est pas nouveau loin s'en
faut sur ce point le rapporteur général
a raison de nous rappeler avec une
constance irréprochable à la comparaison
avec l'allemagne plus de 40 points de
pib c'est par nos taux d'endettement
ce décrochage s'explique par une
succession d'erreurs politiques et
stratégiques passé notamment par une
funeste inspiration la france a décidé
de sacrifier son industrie sur l'autel
des services elle a laissé filer ses
vinh à l'étranger et avec elle les
emplois qualifiés qu'elles offraient
résultat notre balance commerciale comme
notre soldes budgétaires sont devenus
structurellement déficitaire nous avons
réuni les conditions d'un endettement
fatidique avec la pandémie notre dette
publique a explosé le quoi qu'il en
coûte choix tactique rationnelle en tant
qu touba risque aujourd'hui de créer un
précédent il faut vite ont tourné la
page il faut bien sûr réduire les
mesures de soutien temporaire mais aussi
s'attaquer au déficit structurel
or à cet égard monsieur le ministre je
suis au regret de voir que la
trajectoire présenté dans le programme
pas très rassurante car si le déficit
public doit être ramené sous la barre
des 3% du pib d'ici 2027 le taux
d'endettement lui se stabiliserait
autour de 113% du pib et il est peu
probable que la réalité soit finalement
plus favorables que ce que prévoit le
programme
mais cet indicateur qui savent bien
souvent de boussole au pilotage des
finances publiques masque deux autres
types d'endettement qui n'apparaissent
pas dans ce ratio au niveau européen
d'abord à la faveur de la crise
sanitaire si l'on peut parler ainsi et
grâce à l'engagement de la france
l'union européenne s'est pour la
première fois en d t
elle même cet endettement supra étatique
constitue une avancée majeure pour la
construction européenne or le premier
président de la cour des comptes ou là
affirmé en commission des finances le
remboursement des subventions versées à
notre pays dans ce cadre qui s'élève à
75 milliards d'euros n'entrent pas dans
le calcul de notre ratio de dette
publique autrement dit notre dette
serait encore plus élevé si nous y
intégrer y ont tous les crédits avec
lesquels nous avons financé votre plan
relance
il est une autre dette qui n'apparaît
pas dans nos comptes et qui a de quoi
inquiéter cette dette c'est la dette
privée qui concerne à la fois les
entreprises mais aussi les ménages elle
avoisine les 150 % du pib bien au-delà
de la dette publique c'est colossal en
la matière la france a le taux
d'endettement privé le plus élevé des
grands pays européens
le diagnostic est évident nous sommes
plus proches de la grèce que de
l'allemagne bien malheureusement ce
ratio d'endettement privé à ses
fondements les dispositifs d'urgence
mises en oeuvre pendant la crise un
cycle contexte de taux négatifs ont
encouragé les entreprises à s'endetter
massivement
pour recruter et investir les effets
positifs sont donc nombreux mais le
risque existe que nous y ont massivement
financer des entreprises notamment dans
les secteurs des nouvelles technologies
dont les valorisations ont été
artificiellement gonflé
pour parachever ce panorama peu
réjouissant jiwok la dernière facette de
notre endettement la dette climatique
c'est la plus grande urgence celle qui
ne menace pas seulement notre pays mais
la planète entière cette dette
n'apparaît pas non plus dans les comptes
elle ravage nos forêts el tahri nos
ressources en eau notamment or monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues un pays
ravagé par les flammes est en stress
hydrique n'est pas gouvernable ce défi
suppose des investissements massifs dans
un contexte très contraint l'immense
défi de la transition nous impose de
changer nos pas de logiciel mais deux
systèmes d'exploitation pour
engager une stratégie ambitieuse de
désendettement au nom du groupe les
indépendants je voudrais aujourd'hui
vous proposer deux leviers d'action qui
corresponde à deux atouts français et
européens le premier levier le plus
opérationnel
c'est de mobiliser
les pagnes privée qui n'a jamais été
aussi imposante même si on la laisse
finalement peu à peu se faire manger par
l'inflation en mars dernier la banque de
france estimé cette épargne à 175
milliards d'euros je vous le rappelle à
mettre en regard des 100 milliards
consacrés aux plans de relance financés
par la dette c'est ce levier que notre
groupe avait proposé de mobiliser en
suggérant via une proposition de loi
inscrit dans notre espace réservé
d'instaurer un livret dépeint une
garantie pour drainer s'étaient pas
privés vers les territoires l'objectif
réaliser des investissements ambitieux
au profit de la transition écologique et
des infrastructures locales
le second levier ou en asie médias mais
plus structurant c'est de mieux
valoriser les externalités positives et
négatives pour mieux orienter les
décisions des acteurs économiques sous
la contrainte du changement climatique
je veux à cet égard prendre un exemple
dans l'actualité
malheureusement c'est tristement imposer
dans le débat public il s'agit mes chers
collègues de l'exemple de nos forêts
aujourd'hui la valeur économique et
sociale de nos forêts se résume à la
production de bois comme si l'arbre
n'était utile qu'une fois abattu cela
n'est absolument pas satisfaisant car
quand la fureur quand la forêt brûle ce
n'est pas seulement un manque à gagner
c'est un atout en moins pour la
transition écologique je vous proposerai
prochainement un dispositif pour prendre
en compte les externalités positives de
la forêt puits de carbone agents de la
biodiversité filtres à eau et engager
ainsi ce changement de mode de pensée
que j'appelle de mes voeux en conclusion
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
il est urgent de réduire notre dette
qu'elles soient publiques privées ou
écologiques ce programme de stabiliser
de stabilité pardon va dans le bon sens
espérons que le risque le rythme soit
tenue je vous remercie
si chers collègues la parole est à
présent notre collègue madame christine
lagarde
coupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous voilà
réunis au coeur de l'été pour discuter
d'un document stratégique qui va engager
la responsabilité du gouvernement sur sa
gestion des finances publiques pour le
moyen terme alors les propos du
rapporteur général ont parfaitement
illustré le caractère parfois
arbitraires j'ai envie de dire
optimistes des hypothèses retenues sur
l'inflation la croissance le solde
public alors nous aussi un nous
aimerions être aussi optimiste que le
gouvernement mais c'est dans la
continuité de ce qui a déjà été fait
dans lequel fr ou la cour des comptes
fin le plus tôt le conseil des finances
publiques avait une incertitude quand
même deux entre 10 et 15 milliards sur
les recettes qui ont été affectées hier
soir alors le programme de stabilité lui
repose sur une croissance potentielle de
1 35% à partir de 2022 et la croissance
potentielle comme l'a dit rapporteur
général c'est un paramètre déterminant
pour la programmation des finances
publiques en effet elle constitue la
meilleure prévision de la croissance du
pib à moyen terme mais pour être
crédible l'hypothèse de croissance
potentielle doit correspondre un régime
de croissance équilibrée et notre
déficit public le déficit de notre
balance commerciale
la désindustrialisation de notre
économie économie limite notre
croissance potentielle par ailleurs un
nouveau défi s'ouvre devant nous peu
pour ne pas dire pas du tout évoqué dans
ce programme de stabilité la lutte
contre le réchauffement changements
climatiques qui aura des conséquences
sur notre économie et une étude de
rexecode de mai 2022 que je vous invite
tous à lire mesure la marche à franchir
+ 10 % pour les entreprises + 20 % pour
les ménages par rapport au trend
actuelle les éléments d'analysé
rassemblés par un membre du secrétariat
permanent du haut conseil des finances
publiques le conduisent d'ailleurs a
estimé que dans les cinq années qui
viennent la croissance potentielle de
l'économie française serait plutôt
proche de 1% légèrement inférieur ou
supérieur
selon le degré de mise en oeuvre de la
réforme des retraites et le doute est
permis sur cette réforme puisque le
président candidat a rétropédalé dès
l'entre-deux tours
le rendement de l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation n'est pas celui du
report de h2d par notre absence de
courage d'aujourd'hui aura des
conséquences significatives pour nos
enfants nos petits enfants en effet les
projections du cor indique que le taux
de remplacement et le niveau de vie des
retraités passerait de 102 8 % du niveau
de vie des actifs en 2020 à 82 5% en
alors je ne sais pas si je suis une
disciple du stoïcisme en tout cas ce qui
est certain c'est que je distingue bien
ce qui dépend pas directement l'action
du gouvernement l'arrêt du conflit quand
on entre la russie et l'ukraine la
rudesse de l'hiver et ce qui en dépend
et permettez nous d'être inquiet car le
plan de stabilité repose uniquement sur
ce qui ne dépend pas complètement de
l'action du gouvernement la base de
l'inflation le maintien de la croissance
plutôt que sur la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques sur laquelle il a complètement
la main alors depuis plusieurs mois
j'interroge le gouvernement sur la
nature précise des économies qu'ils
envisagent la réponse est toujours aussi
flou le ministre le maire cite toujours
comme vous aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre les mesures en faveur du plein
emploi qui doivent soutenir la
croissance alors permettez-moi de
revenir sur deux sur l'élargissement de
l'apprentissage au lycée professionnel
alors effectivement le succès de cette
politique ne m'a pas échappé le taux
d'emploi des jeunes s'est
considérablement améliorée au détriment
de la productivité de notre économie et
pour un coût important pour les finances
publiques comme l'a d'ailleurs souligne
un rapport du sénat je remarque
d'ailleurs que pour afficher un taux de
croissance annuel moyen de la dépense du
quinquennat 2017 2022 inférieur au
quinquennat précédent vous retraités les
charges liées à la création de france
compétences dans le pestacle oui c'est
je vise le graphique de la passe
trente-et-une sur la mise en place d'un
service public de la petite enfance
effectivement c'est une nécessité cas
comme le relève le programme de
stabilité les prestations familiales ont
considérablement diminuer -3 7% du fait
de la faible natalité de ces dernières
années mais l'objectif de création de
30000 places d'accueil collectif qui
avait pourtant fait l'objet d'un
engagement dans la convention 2018-2022
liant la cnaf et l'état n'a absolument
pas été concrétisées seuls quinze mille
places ont été créées selon un rapport
du ce2 mars 2022 il n'existe pas de
places d'accueil formelle pour 40% des
enfants de moins quand on assiste à une
érosion de l'attractivité de ses métiers
ce mouvement est si fort qu'elle conduit
un nombre important de collectivités
locales a gelé des berceaux et ce n'est
pas leur donnant du 19 mai 2021 sur les
services aux familles où le comité de
filière que vous avez institué en 2021
qui apporte une réponse l on apporter un
début de réponse est d'ailleurs l'avis
du cse de mars 2022 plaide pour une mise
en place d'un droit opposable à la garde
du jeune enfant comme l'a voté
l'allemagne en 2004 mais je voudrais
juste vous dire c'est un objectif
ambitieux avec un coût significatif pour
les finances publiques le coût de
fonctionnement annuel d'une place de
crèche dépasse les 15000 euros et son
coût d'investissement est de l'ordre de
34 mille euros alors au delà de quelques
exemples précis que l'on peut compter
sur les doigts d'une main les propos
relatifs à la maîtrise de la dépense
sont très généreux dans ce document je
vous cite renforcement de la qualité des
dépenses avec un examen systématique de
l'impact environnemental des dépenses
alors juste pour mémoire pour tout le
monde ici les crédits budgétaires et les
taxes à fêter neutre ou non cotées
représente
92% des dépenses intégré à l'objectif
total des dépenses de l'état et dans ce
même document vous nous citer la
plateforme de visualisation développé
pour que le parlement et les citoyens
s'approprient les résultats de l'action
publique mais j'ai été la voir
objectivement il ya que des données
quantitatives absolument pas de
qualitatif je vous cite à nouveau
maîtrise de la dépense sur tous les
successeurs plus 0,6 pour cent en volume
hors urgences et relance en moyenne sur
la période 2023 2027 mais il s'agit
d'une stabilisation du train de vie ne
s'agit pas du tout de véritables
économies par ailleurs plusieurs lois de
programmation sectorielle engage déjà le
gouvernement la loi relative à la
programmation militaire pour lesquels on
entend déjà parler d'une révision avec
une hausse des crédits de 50 milliards
la loi de programmation relative au
développement durable et solidaire la
loi de programmation de la recherche et
récemment le ministre de l'intérieur
annonce une loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'intérieur autour de 16 milliards les
états généraux de la justice doivent
déboucher sur une augmentation des
crédits accordés aux juridictions et à
l'administration pénitentiaire
dans ses perspectives économiques de
juillet 2022 dans le chapitre consacré à
la france l' ocde appelle le
gouvernement à mettre en place une
stratégie ciblée d'assainissement
budgétaire à moyen terme qui fixe des
priorités claires pour garder la
viabilité des finances publiques et
l'efficience de la dépense publique dans
un contexte de hausse du service de la
dette permet moi de vous dire que nous
n'y sommes pas encore alors juste une
question dans votre stratégie j'ai du
mal à voir quelle sera l'effort
réellement demandé aux collectivités le
programme de stabilité évoque une
concertation comme le ministre beji
encore il n'ya pas si longtemps dans cet
hémicycle mais page 38 je vous cite les
dépenses de fonctionnement seraient
maîtrisés en volume et ralentir et en
valeur dans le sillage de l'inflation
alors cette maîtrise en volume c'est en
réalité une baisse comme l'a précisé le
ministre de l'économie le 21 juillet une
baisse de 0 5% mais cette baisse elles
devraient être très importantes sur les
dépenses hors ressources humaines qui
représentent plus de 50 % des dépenses
des collectivités
en effet ces dépenses vont mécaniquement
offense augmenté sous l'effet de la
revalorisation du point d'indicé sous
l'effet de la hausse du smic sous
l'effet du gvt alors si on y ajoute les
prix de l'énergie et de l'alimentation
il ne reste plus une grande marge de
manoeuvre en réalité vous laisser
uniquement les collectivités qu'aux
déterminer les modalités de modération
de leurs dépenses et l'effort demandé
est beaucoup plus important que celui
qui avait été demandé par les contrats
de coeur alors dans le document vous
persistez à dire que cette politique a
été efficace moi je persiste à vous dire
que c'est uniquement la conséquence de
la baisse de la de la baisse de 13
milliards de dotations de l'état entre
2013 et 2017 car oui je voudrais vous
rappeler que les collectivités elles ne
peuvent pas dépenser l'argent qu'elles
n'ont pas sauf à augmenter les impôts
locaux ce qu'elles vont avoir de moins
en moins la capacité de faire avec la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation et
demain de la cvae alors je n'ai pas dit
que nous ne sommes pas favorables à la
politique de réindustrialisation tout au
contraire nous pensons qu'il est
effectivement nécessaire de baisser
notre différentiel de compétitivité avec
l'allemagne mais nous pensons aussi
qu'il est nécessaire de laisser de la
liberté aux collectivités territoriales
dans la gestion de leurs recettes et de
les récompenser de leur action
d'attractivité alors pour conclure notre
pays va continuer de diverger avec les
autres pays de la zone euro l'analyse
des pétales des huit principaux pays de
la zone euro menée par la cour des
comptes dans son dernier rapport sur
l'état des finances publiques
relève que la france serait en 2025
l'art des rares pays qui n'auraient pas
commencer à réduire la dette héritées de
la crise sanitaire l'italie l'espagne
prévoit de réduire leur endettement de
10 points de pib sur la période cette
divergence vient du fait que la france
serait le déficit structurel le plus
élevé des huit pays étudiés alors allez
tonnes vous pouvez compter sur nous et
vous nous trouverez pour défendre une
mesure simple et concrète pour redresser
les comptes publics la mise en place
d'une règle d'or
merci chers collègues je passe la parole
à monsieur guy benarroch du groupe
écologiste pour 8 minutes chers
collègues
ce cas peu distrait
la présidente monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances la commission monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
permettez-moi en préambule et comme
certains l'ont déjà dit de relever la
transmission tardive du programme de
stabilité que trois mois de retard alors
que notre pays assure encore la
présidence de l'union européenne ces
documents sans ces tracés dans
trajectoire de finances publiques a été
reçue une extremis vendredi dernier
traduisant l'absence totale de respect
pour notre travail
il n'est cela dit pas besoin de plus de
temps pour constater le manque de
fiabilité et la sincérité des hypothèses
économiques largement optimiste et
surestimé qui le sous-tendent piocher
dans la fourchette haute des prévisions
certainement car celle plus réaliste de
la banque de france ou des
conjoncturistes était trop tôt barbara
szots l'effet combiné de ces évaluations
en trompe l'oeil et de surestimer la
santé économique du pays est las de
sous-estimer les difficultés des ménages
dans les années à venir malgré vos
efforts de dissimulation vous proposez
bien et bel et bien de réduire
drastiquement le rythme de croissance
des dépenses publiques à 0,6 pour cent
acteurs contrairement à ce que vous
affirmez que nous allons rentrer dans
une période d'austérité il n'y a pas de
surprise dans ce texte quand il est
pétri d'orientation néolibérale et de
mesures anti sociales basées sur des
mesures structurelles telles que
l'aménagement des retraites et de
l'assurance chômage pour faire des
économies et dans les faits inspiré
pourtant est loin d'être certaine force
d'agir sur les recettes comme nous le
préconisons et d'appliquer une fiscalité
plus exigeante sur les hauts revenus et
les profits vous continuez à terme de
faire peser sur les classes moyennes et
populaires les frais de cette politique
puisque les revenus de transferts et
l'accès aux services publics diby durant
provoquant un terme un creusement des
inégalités
car ne nous leurrons pas contrairement à
ce qui a été affirmé les collectivités
ne seront pas épargnés par cette
politique austère alors que beaucoup
d'entre elles sont déjà exergue alors
qu'elles font aussi face à l'inflation
pour leurs dépenses de fonctionnement
une baisse de leurs dépenses à hauteur
de 0 5 % est prévue au dessus de
l'amplification progressive de leur
autonomie qui verra à partir de 2023 la
dernière moitié de la cvae supprimer
les préconisations de votre programme de
stabilité ferait donc inévitablement
pâtir la qualité de service public
auquel vous allez porter un coup fatal
alors qu'il garantisse le dernier lien
avec certains de nos concitoyens les
plus précaires
enfin et surtout l'austérité qui sous
tend ce programme de stabilité n'est pas
compatible avec l'impératif de
conversion écologique le programme
autorisant des hausses ciblées sur les
secteurs prioritaires que sont les
armées l'intérieur la recherche justice
et l'aide publique au développement et
lutte defacto le secteur de l'écologie
qui pourtant a cruellement besoin de
financements publics nous ne cesserons
de le répéter malgré votre obstination
offert un détail de l'histoire il n'est
pas acceptable et même dangereux de
continuer à vous englué dans l'inaction
climatique
on ne prévoyant pas des mesures à la
hauteur des plus grands défis que nous
ayons affronté la programmation que vous
nous présentez et climaticides il
fallait un changement de paradigme clair
vous en êtes incapables et les débats
que nous avons eus il ya peu sur le plfr
ont encore une fois démontré vous auriez
pourtant pu financer ses dépenses
indispensables à notre avenir par les
mesures fiscales juste que nous vous
proposions au coude autre proposait
également yassef climatique ou la
contribution des super profits des
multinationales
mes chers collègues ce que ce document
ne dit pas est plus important que ce
qu'il dit l'austérité est devant nous
alors que les besoins sociaux et
environnementaux sont criants ne pouvoir
avec sincérité de l'émotion programme
ssr sur le ministre vous entêter dans un
système idéologique délétère s'en tirer
les leçons du passé et en voulant
obstinément respecter les impératifs
budgétaires de maastricht dans le seuil
de 3% sans fondement économique avait
été jugée dépassée par le président de
la république lui-même le présent
programme d'exposants ailleurs à
lucienne l'absurdité économique même à
partir de chiffres excessivement
optimiste le gouvernement arrive à peine
à passer sous la barre des 3% en 2027 et
cela sort pour autant réussir à réduire
le niveau honnêtement mes collègues
l'ont déjà dit avant moi et mieux ils
l'ont développé monsieur le ministre il
est grand temps d'être lucide sur
l'incompatibilité structurel entre les
besoins d'investissements publics
immédiat et ambitieux que nous impose la
transition écologique et les règles
budgétaires européennes qui entravent
nos capacités de dépenses publiques
menées ces deux combats de manière
simultanée nous condamne
irrémédiablement a échoué dans les deux
il est grand temps d'avoir le courage de
mettre en place une politique de
soutenabilité budgétaire fondée sur un
principe de soutenabilité économiques et
environnementales et pas seulement sur
des critères comptables vous aurez donc
compris mes chers collègues nous
refusons un programme de stabilité qui
est obsolète avant même d'avoir été mis
en oeuvre et à programme dans
l'optimisme et si farouche qu'il confine
à la malhonnêteté et amorce des mesures
dévastatrice face aux enjeux de taille
qui se présente à nous est
si cher collègue la parole est à présent
monsieur pascal savoldelli du groupe
communiste pour 8 minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues président
de la commission des finances rapporteur
général allait
mieux vaut tard que jamais la france ap
après tous les autres états membres
présentent tant bien que mal son
programme de stabilité
repoussée après les présidentielles ce
programme de stabilité aurait permis de
connaître quand même le programme
électoral du président alors candidat
cette clarification restimuler le débat
critique la démocratie les électeurs
auraient pu constater le peu d'égard d'
emmanuel macron pour la question sociale
le verdict est tombé fin juillet trois
mois après le délai organique prévue au
grand dam du parlement et du haut
conseil pour les finances publiques le
programme de stabilité déjà dans la
boîte aux lettres de la commission
européenne dès lors impossible de
l'infléchir le débat est clos nous
sommes plus à un retard nous sommes plus
un retard près mais croyez moi la
démocratie parlementaire sera s'en
souvenir le programme de stabilité dans
le jargon est censé décret les moyens
mis en oeuvre pour respecter la
contrainte des règles budgétaires
européennes est demeuré en deçà du
déficit de 3% politiquement c'est un
document annuel dans lequel le
gouvernement prête allégeance à l'union
européenne en lui donnant des gages de
libéralisme pour attester d'un prétendu
sérieux budgétaire la perspective n'est
pas réjouissante dans la crise sanitaire
et la crise économique à dominante
inflationniste ou engendrer des dépenses
pour partie incontournable mais jamais
financé à y regarder de plus près la
trajectoire n'est pas heureuse et nul ne
doute qu'elle ne saura être tenu le
gouvernement s'engage à réduire le
déficit public à 3% d'ici 2027
c'est ce qu'a posté ryter conduira le
prochain quinquennat quand je parle du
prochain quinquennat je parle de l'après
mâcon
cet héritage nous conduira à l'impasse
rendant les objectifs économiques
sociaux et écologiques
insoutenable
comment ne pas voir à minima un paradoxe
plus certainement un contresens dans la
stratégie de baisse de la fiscalité pour
réduire les déficits et ce après un
quinquennat qui veut
disqualifié l'impôt on l'a vécu pendant
deux jours là
avec gravité je prends acte que la
redevance de télé va disparaître dans
les prochaines semaines 3,2 milliards de
recettes en moins de la suppression de
la baisse de la cotisation sur la valeur
ajoutée des entreprises la sévère dès
2023 8 milliards de recettes de moins de
la baisse de l'imposition sur les
successions 5 milliards de recettes en
moins faut-il rappeler
et r c'est la soustraction des recettes
et des dépenses
allez je me permets une abstraction
0 ou 1 250 milliard je vais vous dire ça
fait moins 250 milliards et en plus de
l'endettement et en plus de
l'endettement
c'est gravissime et excusez moi monsieur
le ministre mais l'arithmétique et es tu
dans un contexte de remontée des taux de
la banque centrale européenne de 50
points de base une première depuis onze
ans
le risque est grand pour les finances
publiques le temps plus grand que 10%
des obligations émises en 2022 soit
quand même 26 milliards d'euros seront
indexés sur l'inflation ces décisions
nous placent sous joug ou du niveau
général des prix de la zone euro ainsi
que nos créanciers qui vont pas manqué
de réclamer leur dû il nous faudra faire
baisser l'inflation par des politiques
de rigueur pour éviter que comme cette
année 17 milliard supplémentaire soit
versé aux spéculateurs aux titres du
trésor mais le gouvernement évoque un
plan allait il suffirait de soutenir la
croissance et de réduire les dépenses
pour compenser les pertes de recettes
mais là le haut conseil des finances
publiques tout comme les membres du
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes et particulièrement
sceptique sur les prévisions de
croissance prévu cette croissance je
cite n'est pas hors d'atteinte mais un
peu élevé elle permettrait d'accéder au
plein-emploi d'ailleurs expression
mentionné six fois dans le document des
fois qu'on n'aurait pas compris les
mesures évoquées sont extrêmement
préoccupantes je cite la page 4 je cite
cette page l'effet des mesures qui
contribuerait à accroître l'offre de
travail à atteindre le plein emploi
notamment la poursuite de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage la réforme des
retraites la réforme du rsa
l'amélioration de l'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'emploi fin la réforme de
pôle emploi en france travaillent
l'élargissement lycée professionnel du
succès de l'apprentissage la mise en
place d'un service public de la petite
enfance
fin de citation votre projet est clair
forcer les individus à travailler et je
veux vous dire ma formule moi c'est quoi
qui leur en coûte j'ai bien dit quoi
qu'il leur en coûte à n'importe quelle
rémunération à n'importe quelles
conditions
à n'importe quel niveau de qualification
et bien sûr à n'importe quel âge c'est
ce que j'ai appelé est ce qu'on nous
appelons nous
l'insécurité sociale une insécurité
sociale qui est contraire aux besoins de
prospérité des travailleurs et des
entreprises et nous considérons cela
comme une faute politique c'est une
aberration fondamental les privés
d'emploi seraient responsables de leur
sort le patronat lui sera exempt de
toute injonction prenons dans l'ordre
les réformes que nous combattrons les
unes après les autres mais avec des
propositions alternatives la réforme de
l'assurance chômage s'est abattue sur
plusieurs millions de travailleurs un
seul effet plus d'ouverture ou de
rechargement de droits pour les périodes
en emplois de moins de six mois
ces gens travaillerait mais pas assez
regardez la réalité que vous avez appelé
le marché de l'emploi en 2021 près de 15
millions de contrats de moins d'un mois
ont été signés et représente 64 % des
embauches réalisées
finalement selon l'unedic 1,15 million
de demandeurs d'emploi vont alors
allocation mensuelle diminué et attendez
pas de peu à 2 17 % en moyenne
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
compter sur notre mobilisation il n'y
aura pas d' acte 2 pour l'assurance
chômage un des piliers de notre modèle
social
la réforme des retraites une réforme
injuste brutale de la vie de toutes les
organisations syndicales
heureusement elle a pas encore lieu loin
de la réforme systémique abandonné après
un mouvement social d'ampleur et grâce à
une majorité de rejet une réforme
paramétrique pourtant un report à l'âge
de 65 ans est réapparu dans la campagne
présidentielle il faudrait travailler
plus longtemps pour financer les
cotisations d'un nombre de retraités
plus important et vous au chai la tête
pensez vous êtes d'accord moi je
considère que c'est un dogme mais pas
tout seul prendre 5 % des 50-64 ans sont
déjà au chômage seules ministre les
faire travailler plus longtemps va
réduire les versements de l'assurance
vieillesse au détriment de l'assurance
chômage et plus l'âge reculera plus
chômage augmentera la voilà la belle
affaire aucune urgence de presse
pourtant le conseil d'orientation des
retraites ne cesse de le rappeler les
dépenses de retraites vont baisser
jusqu'à
ib en 2035 soit l'un des plus bas niveau
en europe et on devrait enregistrer des
excédents en 2070 conséquence d'une
mutation démographique que l'on se le
dise mes chers collègues la réforme des
retraites n'a pas vocation à combler des
déficits des retraites mais à financer
d'autres dépenses sociales
bruxelles et les marchés financiers le
demande et là vous gourmand le
gouvernement vous en réjouissez a -
enfin sur les raisins conditionnait une
quinzaine d'heures de travail nous
allons créer des travailleurs parmi les
plus précaires d'europe en dessous du
smic comme si les allocataires du rsa se
complaisait dans la pauvreté
575 euros c'est des incitatifs monsieur
le ministre c'est des incitatifs au
travail c'est évident remettons les gens
au travail quoi qu'il leur en coûte vous
disais-je
le haut conseil pour les finances puis
vous le dit l'impact de ces réformes
paraît nettement surestimé puisqu'il est
présumé se manifester dès 2023 alors que
toutes les réformes comparable
entreprises dans le passé ont non
seulement les cécités du temps pour leur
formalisation et leur mise en oeuvre
mais également pour produire des effets
durables sur la population effectivement
d'emplois alors monsieur le ministre
nous sommes là parce que satisfaire
bruxelles et les marchés financiers sur
le dos des travailleurs sur le dos des
français est une orientation politique
aux antipodes de nos valeurs et nos
aspirations vous ne gardez pas de la
côte mais vous n'avez pas gardé de la
commission à peine provisions favorable
excusez moi mais regardez avant-hier au
moins il y avait une bonne proposition
de la commission européenne taxer les
super profits allaient fin de non
recevoir
vous avez compris ce n'est pas un
programme de stabilité c'est un
programme de gouvernement des droites
donc nous y proposons merci de votre
attention
merci chers collègues je passe la parole
à présent à monsieur jean michel arnaud
du groupe union centriste
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes parole
madame la présidente les ministres mes
chers collègues le gouvernement nous
présente le programme de stabilité pour
2022 27 avec comme cela a été rappelé
par plusieurs orateurs plus de trois
mois de retard sur la date butoir ce
retard est d'autant plus dommageable que
notre pays assurait alors la présidence
de l'union européenne et qui lui était
intéressant que ce programme ne soient
présentés y compris au moment du débat
national des élections législatives ce
retard traduit aussi un certain manque
de respect du travail du parlement et de
sa mission essentielle d'évaluation et
de contrôle ce document est également
examinée à la hâte alors qu'il est
essentiel puisqu'il traces la
trajectoire des finances publiques pour
toute la durée du nouveau quinquennat ce
document appelle plusieurs remarques
tout d'abord permettez moi de vous dire
que nous doutons de la fiabilité des
prévisions associées à ce programme de
stabilité concernant les perspectives de
croissance potentielle et comme il ya
cinq ans vous prévoyez un taux qui
doublerait sur la durée de la mandature
passant de 1 euro donnez moi un virus
25% à 2 50% vous partez d'une prévision
supérieure à celles la commission
européenne qui mise quant à elle sur un
taux plus raisonnables de 1% vous pariez
même sur une accélération de la
croissance du pib à 1 8 % en 2025
laquelle résultera des réformes engagées
notamment et cela a été dit également
celle des retraites et de l'assurance
chômage dont nous savons qu'elles
produiront tous leurs effets qu'à moyen
terme nous savons également que le
calendrier n'est pas que physique fixés
en terme de discussions nous ne savons
pas quand ces mesures s'appliqueront ni
combien rapporteront dans ce contexte
comment pourrions nous être en mesure
d'en évaluer l'impact sur les finances
publiques
enfin un rapide coup d'oeil sur
l'évolution du ratio des prélèvements
obligatoires sur pib montrent que la
pression fiscale d'une diminuera pas
contrairement à ce que nous laisse
croire ou lorsqu'on laisse croire aux
contes rival français en effet le
gouvernement annonce baisser les
prélèvements obligatoires c'est à dire
les impôts et les cotisations sociales
or si l'on en croit le projet de
programme de stabilité pour les années
2000 22 à 2027 le taux de prélèvements
obligatoires resterait pratiquement
stable jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat en
réalité les baisses concédé et afficher
compte elle dans le discours politique
du gouvernement correspondent à des
rétrocessions partielle de retrait ce de
recettes de recettes fiscales lesquels
augmente spontanément du fait de la
conjoncture économique mais ces baisses
ne correspondent aucunement à des
baisses structurelles d'imposition et
pour se permettre de telles baisses
encore faudrait-il être en mesure de
baisser les dépenses publiques en regard
sauf à rejeter inconsciemment le fardeau
des déficits et la dette publics sur les
épaules des faits des générations
futures nous avons aujourd'hui un ratio
de dépenses publiques équivalent à 57 3%
du pib ce qui est le reflet d'un état
qui dépensent souvent trop et surtout
qu'ils dépensent mal souvent au
détriment des services public et de nos
infrastructures les plus essentiels
comme cela a été rappelé à plusieurs
reprises lors du débat sur le projet de
loi de finances rectificative en matière
d'infrastructures notamment ferroviaires
et de transport
comment monsieur le ministre comptez
vous en disiez cette dérive la lecture
de ce projet de programme de stabilité
ne nous permet pas de trouver la réponse
ne serait ce que des éléments à cette
question aujourd'hui vital nous pouvons
lire dans le document qu'une réduction
des dépenses publiques de l'ordre de
huit milliards d'euros par an est
attendu à partir de 2024 à quoi
correspondent ces milliards d'où
viendront concrètement ces économies
vous le savez nous sommes ici au sénat
particulièrement vigilants sur la
trajectoire proposé pour les
collectivités locales il est évoqué une
réduction des dépenses de fonctionnement
de l'ordre 0 5% en volume sans plus de
précisions or emmanuel macron alors
président candidat annoncé faire peser
sur les seules collectivités
territoriales un effort de plus de 10
milliards d'euros sur cinq ans depuis en
fonction des déclarations du ministre le
maire en fonction des déclarations du
ministre béchu en ne voit plus
véritablement ou la ligne de conduite le
flou règne monsieur le ministre quels
seront les objectifs qui seront fixées
aux collectivités territoriales est-ce
que les contrats de cahors cette
contribution des collectivités au
redressement des comptes publics va-t-il
être vont ils être ressuscité les locaux
dont nous sommes au sein de cette haute
assemblée les relais aimerait y voir
beaucoup plus clair
le groupe union centriste et mes
collègues ici présentes présent par don
sylvie vermeillet et michel canévet ont
eu l'occasion d'insister sûr ce point
tout au long de la discussion du projet
de loi de finances rectificative et tout
particulièrement inquiet par
l'emballement notre endettement public
en 2027 nous devrions d'après vos
prévisions rester au même niveau que
2021 soit 112 points 5 % du pib en 2027
aussi nous devrions et c'est indique
également dans le document être le seul
pays de la zone euro a enregistré près
de 3% des déficits
voilà me semble-t-il monsieur le
ministre toute la difficulté auquel nous
sommes confrontés mais ça semble aussi
reposer sur une hypothèse dangereusement
optimiste une contre performance d'un
point sur le niveau de croissance et le
plafond des 120 % seraient pulvérisées
nous nous savons qu'il n'ya pas d'argent
magique les innovations futures devront
payer espérons que dans quelques
semaines à la rentrée vous ne l'avez
indiqué que l'ensemble de ces questions
trouveront ces premières réponses
déquilibre à l'automne lors la
présentation de la nouvelle loi de
programmation des finances publiques il
ya urgence à ce que nous fixions
collectivement un cap quant au
redressement de nos comptes publics afin
d'éviter
que l'état est finalement les français
se retrouvent en situation de ruines je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent à monsieur bernard fialaire
sénateurs du groupe rds vous avez huit
minutes
ch mois
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
proposer chaque année un programme de
stabilité tenir les promesses qui
contient et même s'en approcher et il en
exercice vain
la fin de la pandémie annonçait des
jours meilleurs sur le plan économique
jusqu'à ce que la guerre en ukraine
vienne repousser cet espoir comment
prévoir de l'économiquement stables dans
un environnement géopolitique instable
l'équation est difficile
à la lecture du programme de stabilité
2021 et 2027 transmis ladern l'année
dernière à bruxelles il était question
d'un rebond de l'activité économique en
2022 de 4% puis 2,3 pour cent en 2023
finalement monsieur le ministre nous
devrions nous contenter d'une croissance
de seulement 2,5 pour cent cette année
et 1,4 pour cent l'année prochaine à la
fin de l'année 2021 l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire de morel principal
allié à mais voilà aujourd'hui nous
sommes face à une crise sévère des prix
de l'énergie des matières premières
comme on sait il en résulte actuellement
une inflation très forte près de 5% et
un niveau de plus en plus difficile à
supporter pour nos concitoyens les plus
modestes sans oublier les entreprises
qui doivent brutalement gérer des
hausses de coûts de production
dans ces conditions quelles sont les
nouvelles perspectives pour les années
2000 22 à 2027
monsieur le ministre vous semblez
pouvoir conserver une trajectoire
financière qui ramènerait le déficit
public sous le seuil des 3% à l'horizon
2027 grâce à un ajustement structurel de
0,3 point de pib par an à compter de
2024 vous comptez aussi contenir la
dette à terme
certains diront coup péché par excès
d'optimisme
la cour des comptes doute en effet sans
toutefois remettre en cause votre
stratégie à deux jambes le soutien à la
croissance et la maîtrise des finances
publiques
si la politique du quoi qu'il en coûte a
été essentielle à la stabilisation notre
économie il étant bien entendu de
revenir à une certaine modération sans
toutefois grippe et la croissance en
particulier son principal moteur la
départ la demande dans cet esprit dans
le cadre de l'examen du texte sur
pouvoir d'achat et du projet de loi de
finances rectificative mon groupe rdse
s'est montré ouvert et constructif nous
avons en effet approuvé le bouclier très
tarifaire l'art vidéo la revalorisation
des pensions de retraite et d'invalidité
des prestations familiales des minima
sociaux et des bourses étudiantes ou
encore la revalorisation du point
d'indicé de la fonction publique mais il
est certain que
certaines de ces mesures n'ont pas
vocation à durer aussi un des principaux
enjeux de votre programme de stabilité
vous l'avez clairement affirmé c'est
l'emploi plus précisément le plein
emploi
la réforme de france travaille la
poursuite de celle de l'apprentissage et
la hausse du smic sont des leviers que
vous avez choisi pour baisser le chômage
à travers cette politique je perçois la
revalorisation du travail ce qui envoie
un signal positif à mon sens
toutefois je m'interroge sur le retour
au plein emploi et vos hypothèses de
productivité la croissance potentielle
ne sera pas forcément la croissance
acquise
sur le volet maîtrise des dépenses
publiques
je rappellerai tout d'abord que mon
groupe le rds on n'est pas un ayatollah
de l'orthodoxie budgétaire
les politiques d'austérité ne mène
jamais bien loin comme on l'a constaté
après la crise de 2007 2008 à ceux qui
les prononcent rappelons que l'union
européenne elle même s'en écarte
désormais assez facilement
certes la dette doit redevenir
soutenable
c'est une responsabilité que nous avons
à l'égard des générations futures d'une
part c'est aussi un enjeu de crédibilité
de l'économie française d'autre part
il faut en apaiser les tensions sur nos
obligations souveraines
le gouvernement souhaite que les
dépenses en volume de l'état ne
progressent pas de +0 4% par an pour
cette saint cet effort n'en est pas un
il est vrai qu'à l'horizon 2027 la dette
restera encore élevé avec un taux de
plus de 112 % du pib
je demande comment faire autrement alors
que beaucoup de nos services publics ont
des besoins immenses que ce soit
l'éducation qui n'est pas simplement une
dépense de fonctionnement mais aussi un
investissement pour l'avenir la santé la
police sans parler du défi climatique
dont on nous dit qu'il nécessiterait une
mobilisation de plusieurs dizaines de
milliards d'euros par an pour la france
mais qui pourraient aussi un levier
d'activité je n'oublie pas les
collectivités locales qui doivent
conserver les moyens de poursuivre leur
action dont certaines on l'a bien vu en
temps de crise constitue un amortisseur
social
les associations d'élus s'inquiète des
nouvelles contraintes que leur impose le
programme de stabilité une augmentation
de leurs dépenses de fonctionnement de 0
5% de moins par rapport à leur tendance
naturelle cela alors que l'inflation
l'inflation va peser lourdement sur leur
investissement
monsieur le ministre au regard d'un
équilibre à trouver entre soutien à la
croissance et maîtrise des finances
publiques se pose la question des impôts
vous avez indiqué ne pas vouloir les
augmenter cette position est louable
mais un profond travail en direction des
niches fiscales doit être envisagée a
minima
faut-il rappeler que lorsque l'impôt est
juste ciblées et sa finalité bien
expliqué il se prête mieux au
consentement
certes on ne peut pas ignorer que la
france apparaît au sein de l'union
européenne comme le mauvais élève
concernant le poids de ces prélèvements
obligatoires c'est un fait cependant il
est bon de rappeler dans le même temps
que les états membres se livre encore
aujourd'hui à une concurrence fiscale
intra européenne dont la france ne sort
pas gagnante quand nous mettons en place
un impôt sur les grandes fortunes des
particuliers s'installe en belgique
quand les impôts sur les sociétés sont
trop élevés les autres des entreprises
des portes leur siège en irlande par
conséquent la commission européenne doit
s'attaquer plus frontalement au problème
du manque de coordination des politiques
budgétaires
cela suppose comme le rdse le rappelle
régulièrement dans les débats sur
l'europe de revoir la règle de la
majorité qualifiée pour certaines
décisions en l'occurrence fiscale le
véto hongrois sur la taxation minimale
international des entreprises illustrent
cette nécessité urgente les dernières
crises ont démontré que les solutions
passe est de plus en plus par l'europe
par la solidarité qu'elle est capable de
mettre en place au fond de la bim les
prochains mois s'annoncent encore
difficiles en particulier pour certains
pays je pense à l'italie et les écarts
de taux d'intérêt menace la cohésion au
sein de l'union
le programme de stabilité dont débattent
aujourd'hui est une sorte de boussole
demandé à bruxelles par bruxelles c'est
un engagement européen chaque état prend
dans son coin au risque que les
boussoles n'indique pas toutes la même
direction
resserré les rangs entre les états
membres et donc fondamental merci
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent à madame nadine bureaux du
groupe l'est républicain
chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur président de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
général c'est avec des finances
publiques parmi les plus dégradées de la
zone euro que nous entamons ce nouveau
quinquennat nous héritons d'un déficit
public qui est plus de deux fois
supérieur à celui de 2010 est et d'une
dette publique qui a progressé de 17 %
en cinq ans la cote d' alerte est
atteinte nous étions nombreux à le
penser nous voilà confortés dans notre
diagnostic dont vous comptez astier la
pertinence il ya quelques mois il est
donc de notre responsabilité d'aborder
ce débat avec lucidité et prudence
lucidité quant aux effets de l'inflation
et de la hausse des taux d'intérêt sur
la dette l'horizon n'est pas cinq ans
mais plutôt à 10 ou 15 ans prudence sur
les prévisions qui font de la vision
stratégique que vous nous proposez le
haut conseil des finances publiques a
rappelé leur fragilité musique
inflationniste ne s'éteindra pas l'an
prochain ni même dans quatre ans tant
les raisons structurelles qui le portent
sont fortes et cumulatives il faudra
donc dépenser bien dépenser utilement
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
ministre
cela veut dire soutenir le niveau
d'investissements publics notamment
locales qui constituent un appui
indispensable à notre économie il y a de
ce point de vue un manque de cohérence
dans le programme de stabilité
à l'instar des fameux contrat de cahors
il prévoit d'imposer une nouvelle fois
un encadrement des dépenses des
collectivités elles devront augmenter de
0 5% de moins que leur tendance
naturelle mais elle augmenterait
cependant en valeur de 24 milliards sur
le quinquennat
l'effort demandé aux collectivités sur
leurs dépenses de fonctionnement serait
de 15 milliards d'euros sur les cinq
prochaines années par rapport à l'année
2022 selon les estimations de
l'association des maires de france
l'encadrement de l'autofinancement et de
vous l'évolution des recettes réduit
longs crocs l'offre de service des
populations à la population et
constitueront risque pour le pouvoir
d'achat dans un contexte où la
consommation des ménages reculent
l'encadrement des dépenses de
fonctionnement apparaît contradictoire
dans un contexte de relance malgré
marquée par le besoin d'investissement
et de soutien aux acteurs locaux en 2021
les seuls d'exécution des collectivités
était proche de zéro
il est donc incompréhensible est
inconcevable qu'elle continue à être
pénalisés encadrer ces dépenses
viendrait à reproduire les erreurs du
passé depuis 2014 la baisse des
dotations a coûté 14 46 milliard d'euros
à l'ensemble des collectivités locales
cela a été sans effet sur le déficit de
l'état qui est même reparti à la hausse
en volume depuis 2018 les collectivités
se voient imposer depuis trop longtemps
la formule essayer de faire mieux avec
moins les efforts ne peuvent pas à
nouveau reposer sur elle dans un
contexte marqué par une inflation record
les communes attendent al'inverse une
revalorisation de leurs recettes pour
assurer la continuité des services
publics locaux essentiels à la
population une réponse rapide est
possible que nous devrons aborder lors
de l'examen de la loi de finances comme
cela fut le cas jusqu'en 2010 il est
nécessaire d'indexer l'évolution de
l'âge et dgf sur l'inflation chaque
année depuis la reprise de l'inflation
la dgf a été amputée d'un milliard
d'euros il est urgent monsieur ministres
de faire droit à cette demande de nos
élus locaux largement partagée et ainsi
de reconstruire une relation financière
basée sur la confiance entre l'état et
les collectivités
vous vous êtes dit prêt à la réforme
sachez que nous le sommes aussi je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
enfin la parole est à notre collègue
alain dufour du groupe union centriste
vous avez quatre minutes chers collègues
nabeul président monsieur le ministre
sur le rapporteur mes chers collègues le
programme de stabilité 2021 et 2027
soumis au parlement dresse la
trajectoire et les perspectives pour nos
finances publiques à l'horizon 2027 il a
marqué par les conséquences de la guerre
en ukraine les traditions
inflationnistes l'impact des mesures du
ségur de la santé dispositif d'urgence
la crise sanitaire
l'administration de sécurité sociale qui
représente la moitié de la dépense
publique devront participer à la
modération des dépenses ou même titre
que lecteur les collectivités
territoriales naseaux ration de 0,6 pour
cent par an en volume les finances
sociales ont supporté la crise sanitaire
les exonérations adopté depuis de
nombreuses années ont grevé le budget de
la sécurité sociale et la reprise la
dette sociale par la cades à hauteur de
130 6 milliards d'euros en 2020 à
évacuer pour longtemps la perspective
d'évacuer d'apurer ses dettes la
trajectoire de retour à l'équilibré en
matière de finances le social restent
floues nous l'avons critiqué dans le
cadre du plfss 2021 et en 2022 locaux et
des finances publiques est si bonne
précise les promesses de réformes du
programme de stabilité la santé
demeurent la priorité numéro un des
français nos urgences nos hôpitaux le
personnel qui travaille sont depuis
longtemps installé dans une situation
critique devenue insupportable l'accès
au saut et reste comme promis pour les
france et dans de nombreux territoires
face aux dépenses qu'implique ces enjeux
légitime et dans le respect d'un budget
équilibré la voie sera étroite pour
trouver financer les solutions a tenu le
défi est grand faire plus avec autant
sur le ministre groupe union centriste
nous souhaitons plusieurs propositions
complémentaires à la réforme des
retraites système complexe et fragmentée
sollicité par la commission européenne
il ya eu des erreurs la cour des comptes
dans son rapport annuel de certification
des comptes de la sécurité sociale 2000
20e souligne l'impact des erreurs sur
les finances sociales je ne veux je ne
relèverai que celles de la branche
maladie les français y sont de leur
poche pour 2,5 milliards d'euros 2,6 du
montant des frais de santé suit la
pertinence des soins le rapport de jean
marie van lerberghe de 2017 souligne
qu'une part d'intervention sans valeur
ajoutée pour la santé constitue une
forme de gaspillage que l' ocde évalue à
peu près d'un cinquième des dépenses de
santé les voies d'économies sont connues
elles correspondent à des soins adaptés
tels que des césariennes aux examens
d'imagerie non justifiées des sur
prescription d'antibiotiques ou encore
le recours aux urgences hospitalières
inutiles ou inévitable en fait la lutte
contre la fraude dans notre collègue
nathalie goulet que nombreux rapports
dénoncé l'existence d'une fraude
importante nous attendons que les
caisses de sécurité sociale il travaille
tout offert l'étape la cartographie des
risques n'est pas celle du déploiement
d'actions correctrices la méthode est la
bonne mais il faut continuer d'avancer
vite en traitant l'ensemble des champs
enfin l'ondam a sans nul doute permis de
juguler la dette sociale toutefois
l'état des lieux d'entre eux mais lucide
tard l'hôpital cavill dans nos forces et
à interroger la pertinence de cet outil
très singulier à la france si nous
sommes attachés à l'objectif du
programme stabilité nous le pouvons
ignorer des politiques publiques
concernées la santé figure au rang des
plus fondamental les établissements
publics de santé ou d'intérêt collectif
porte des missions de service public
le principe de rentabilité est
relativement d'antinomique au principe
de service public aussi le maintien d'un
service d'une unité ou d'un hôpital de
proximité ne peut pas être décidé
uniquement sous l'angle budgétaire
au vu de ces éléments vous avez dressé
monsieur le ministre tout à l'heure un
tableau idyllique de notre pays ne l'en
situation financière tout en fustigeant
même temps des formations politiques que
légalement constitué or la réalité est
tout autre
la dette publique 2000 2009 5 milliards
d'euros soit 11,5 pour cent du pib une
hausse et des prix à 2021 de 6,1 pour
cent qui ne cesse de s'aggraver un taux
de chômage 7,3 pour cent et enfin la
france est championne du monde des
prélèvements sociaux obligatoires
hauteur de 46 pouces à voir la vérité
non aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre
nous vous donnons rendez vous l'examen
du plfss à l'automne prochain en
attendant des propositions concrètes de
votre part est une tragique trajectoire
vertueuse et des finances sociales voilà
ce qu'attend notre pays et ce
qu'attendent les français aujourd'hui
tout à fait légitimement je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues
j'essaie de la parole à monsieur gabriel
attal ministre délégué en charge des
comptes publics pour nous apporter des
réponses
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs très rapidement
puisque nous aurons l'occasion de
débattre de la trajectoire des finances
publiques au moment de la présentation
de la loi de programmation du projet de
loi de programmation des finances
publiques qui sera présenté au mois de
septembre est débattu à l'automne c'est
pour répondre à l'un des intervenants
monsieur moïse et je crois qu'il
demandait quel était le calendrier pour
cette lpfp ce sera donc en parallèle du
projet de loi de finances pour 2023 mais
quelques mots quand même pour répondre
au sujet aux interpellations qui sont
revenus le plus régulièrement dans les
différentes interventions sur le
calendrier d'abord effectivement nous
présentons à la représentation nationale
et transmettons à la commission
européenne son programme de stabilité
avec du retard
c'est loin d'être la première fois qu'un
état transmet son programme de stabilité
avec du retard et déjà arriver ça
arrivera probablement encore et bien
souvent s'était lié à des échéances
électorales effectivement nous avons
fait un choix nous avons fait un choix
de préparer ce programme de stabilité
après les échéances électorales pourquoi
puisque nous attachons une importance
toute particulière au vote des français
aux choix des français au cours des
élections et que si nous avions présenté
un programme de stabilité avant les
élections cela même aujourd'hui qui nous
qui nous reproche de le faire trop tard
nous aurait reproché de l'avoir fait
avant cette échéance démocratique majeur
en expliquant qu'on engageait la france
sur un programme de stabilité avant même
que les français est plus décidé du
président de résidente de la république
et de la majorité qui lui donnait c'est
donc une preuve de respect pour la
représentation nationale que d'avoir
attendu que les français se prononcent à
l'occasion des élections pour présenter
un programme de stabilité le sénat n'a
pas évolué n'a pas changé de couleur
politique entre avant et après les
élections mais l'assemblée nationale a
sensiblement évolué et le débat que nous
avons eu hier à l'assemblée nationale
n'aurait pu avoir lieu si nous avions
présenté programmes de stabilité avant
les échéances électorales c'est donc une
marque de respect pour la représentation
nationale ensuite il nous a fallu par
ailleurs quelques semaines pour tenir
compte de la situation internationale et
macroéconomique puisque la réalité c'est
que nous ne sommes plus dans le même
monde est dans le même environnement
macroéconomique qu'au mois d'avril et
que d'ailleurs si notre programme de
stabilité arrive après celui des autres
il est probablement plus juste que celui
des autres puisqu'il tient compte de la
situation
macroéconomique mondiale actuelle qui
s'est sensiblement dégradée depuis le
mois d'avril où nous en étions qu'aux
prémices du conflit l'ukrainien voilà
pour le calendrier sur les prévisions
ensuite j'ai eu l'occasion de dire dans
mon intervention en discussion générale
qu'il est évidemment toujours difficile
de se livrer à un exercice de prévision
encore plus quand on est soumis à des
aléas tels que ceux que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui avec la situation sanitaire
est avec la guerre en ukraine pour
autant je le redis nos prévisions celle
que nous avons inscrit dans le programme
de stabilité sur la base des travaux de
la direction générale du trésor sont
solides et crédibles et je sais que un
certain nombre de doutes ont été émis
notamment par le haut conseil aux
finances publiques je constate cependant
que le haut conseil aux finances
publiques dans son avis a remis en
question effectivement
la certitude ou l'exactitude de nos
prévisions de croissance y compris pour
2022 en expliquant que ne semblait pas
tout à fait certain que nous puissions
atteindre 2 5% de croissance en 2022 le
lendemain de la publication de l'avis du
haut conseil aux finances publiques
l'insee a confirmé que nous avions
atteint 2 5% de croissance en 2022 et
nous avons vu ces dernières années dans
le quinquennat précédent quand même que
nous avions atteint un certain nombre
d'objectifs dont on nous expliquait au
début du quinquennat qu'il semblait
inatteignable quand emmanuel macron a
été élu en 2017 il a expliqué qu'il
visait 7 % de chômage en 2022 on a
exploré entendu beaucoup de
personnalité pour expliquer que c'était
inatteignable de viser 7 % de chômage
cinq ans plus tard en 2022 nous y sommes
ou quasiment et donc quand nous
indiquons que nous visons le plein
emploi pour la fin du prochain
quinquennat
nous pouvons y arriver pour atteindre le
plein emploi il faut créer ou que soient
créées dans le quinquennat qui s'ouvre
un million deux cent mille emplois
c'est le nombre d'emplois qui ont été
créés dans le quinquennat qui vient de
s'écouler grâce à la politique en faveur
du travail de l'investissement et de la
compétitivité des entreprises qui a été
engagé par le président de la république
et par son gouvernement c'est pour ça
que nous voulons poursuivre c'est pour
ça que nous voulons poursuivre les
réformes
j'ai entendu un appel à un certain
nombre de réformes et donc je me réjouis
par avance de bénéficier du soutien de
ceux qui appellent à ces réformes quand
nous présenterons la réforme de
l'assurance chômage dans sa nouvelle
version quand nous présenterons la
réforme des
nous présenterons la réforme de
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
quand nous présenterons la réforme du
lycée professionnel pour que le succès
de l'apprentissage se vérifie aussi dans
la voie professionnelle scolaire tout ça
nous allons le présenter à la rentrée
j'espère que nous pourrons compter sur
le soutien de celles et de ceux qui
appellent à ces réformes puisque je le
redis le coeur de notre stratégie
économique le coeur de la stratégie pour
tenir nos comptes c'est l'activité
économique et c'est l'emploi et c'est ce
que nous avons démontré ces derniers
mois encore et ces dernières années et
ce sur quoi nous voulons insister je
parlais des prévisions pour 2022 qui
s'était d'ores et déjà réalisé pour les
années suivantes aussi je le redis elles
sont crédibles 2023 nous prévoyons 1 4%
de croissance c'est exactement la
prévision qui vient d'être faite par la
commission européenne qui a remis son
avis à la mi-juillet et je redis ce que
j'ai entendu l'intervenant notamment du
groupe socialiste remettre en question
la prévision de croissance à 1 8% pour
2027 que le fc eux qui est quand même
souvent citée en exemple et en référence
par les groupes de gauche lui même nous
met une prévision de croissance
supérieure à celle que nous inscrivons
en 2027 1,9 pour cent c'est donc bien
que c'est tout à fait atteignable et que
c'est que c'est possible
je veux ensuite revenir sur les
certitudes ce que dans cet océan
d'incertitudes dans ses aléas évidemment
c'est important d'avoir des certitudes
la première certitude je l'évoquais à
l'instant c'est de mettre l'activité
économique l'emploi au coeur de notre
stratégie nous allons continuer à le
faire avec les réformes que j'évoquais
la deuxième c'est notre détermination
absolue à tenir nos comptes et je le
redis nous allons maîtriser la dépense
oui et j'ai entendu tout à la fois
certains expliqué que la trajectoire que
nous avions annoncée dans le programme
de stabilité c'était du sang et des
larmes et de l'autre côté certains
expliqué que c'était pas d'effort du
tout c'est donc bien que ce doit être
une trajectoire équilibré ce sont des
efforts faut le dire et la réalité c'est
que 1 0 6% de croissance en volume sur
le quinquennat c'est le plus gros
efforts faits depuis vingt ans en
matière de dépenses publiques c'est une
réalité faut le dire et je réponds au
rapporteur général qui semble s
inquiéter qu'il n'y ait pas
baisse des dépenses en 2023 je lui dis
d'ailleurs le tiré à part sera transmis
dans les tout prochains jours sur les
plafonds ministériel pour 2023 je lui
indique que la dépense
que la dépense publique baissera de 3%
en volume en 2023 c'est ce qui sera
proposé par le projet de loi de finances
et donc nous allons poursuivre cette
trajectoire tout au long du quinquennat
la deuxième certitude c'est que
cette maîtrise de la dépense ne se fera
pas de manière aveugle au rabot uniforme
nous faisons des choix politiques là
aussi c'est pour répondre à un certain
nombre d'interventions nous l'avons dit
nous faisons le choix de continuer à
investir pour la santé pour le système
de santé et donc dans les grands sous
secteur le seul sous secteur qui verra
sa dépenses augmenter en volume c'est le
secteur de la santé parce que nous nous
faisons le choix de continuer à investir
massivement comme nous l'avons fait ces
dernières années dans la santé et dans
l'hôpital je le rappelle le budget de
l'hôpital public en 2010 7 79 milliards
d'euros le budget de l'hôpital public en
2022 95 milliards d'euros nous avons
massivement investi pour la santé pour
l'hôpital public et nous allons
continuer à le faire nous allons
investir massivement pour l'éducation
aussi c'est un choix ministère de
l'éducation fait partie des ministères
c'est le ministère qui verra son budget
augmenter le plus l'an prochain en 2023
notamment pour financer l'engagement du
président de la république de
revalorisation de 10% du salaire des
enseignants sur un an celles qui s'y est
engagé pendant la campagne
présidentielle
nous allons continuer à investir aussi
pour la sécurité des français avec
effectivement la loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'intérieur 15 milliards d'euros sur le
quinquennat la poursuite de leur
programmation militaire et le respect
des marches qui ont été votées par
l'assemblée nationale et par le sénat 3
milliards d'euros l'an prochain qui
seront tenues je terminerai en répondant
absurde intervention que j'ai entendu
semblait opposer la tenue de nos comptes
et la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique ou la transition énergétique
ça fait écho à une intervention que j'ai
entendu hier à l'assemblée nationale
d'une députée insoumise qui expliquait
entre les trois les entre les 3% les
trois degrés il faut choisir et moi je
pense précisément l' inverse je pense
que si nous nous mettons ça dans la tête
si nous considérons que la tenue de nos
comptes est un obstacle à la transition
énergétique nous ne parviendrons pas à
accomplir la transition énergétique
on voit aujourd'hui à quel point la
dette nous prive d'un certain nombre de
marges de manoeuvre cette année elles
nous coûtent 17 milliards de plus ces
deux fois le budget du ministère de la
justice si nous continuons à laisser si
les ailes nous privera de tellement de
marge de manoeuvre que nous n'aurons
plus les moyens d'investir pour la
transition énergétique et pour la
transition écologique tenir nos comptes
c'est donc un moyen de continuer à faire
des choix politiques et c'est pour ça je
crois que chacune et chacun d'entre nous
sont élus faire des choix politiques au
service des français je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je vais suspendre la séance
pour quelques instants afin de permettre
à chacun de s'installer pour le prochain
point à l'ordre du jour la séance est
suspendue